ils ont commencé cette audition enfin
cette table ronde plus exactement
puisque vous êtes nombreux pour pouvoir
animer cette table ronde et répondre à
nos questions sur tout ce qui touche au
patrimoine donc je vous remercie bien
évidemment de vous être rendu disponible
pour participer à cette audition qui
vise à prendre en compte des questions
de patrimoine dans les politiques de
rénovation énergétique donc nous
recevons aujourd'hui les représentants
alors je pense que ma liste est au
complet ou en tout cas certains vont
encore nous rejoindre en particulier
notre collègue Françoise Gatel donc les
représentants de 9 organismes Monsieur
Jean-François Hébert ah voilà je vais
chercher pardon directeur général des
patrimoines et de l'architecture
donc notre collègue c'est la triste
d'Ille-et-Vilaine Madame Françoise Gatel
en sa qualité voilà qui rentre à
l'instant
présidente de petites cités de
caractères de France bienvenue Françoise
et Monsieur Guirec Aaron mère de
Tréguier qui devrait nous rejoindre
monsieur le ministre Martin Malvy
il est en visio ah il est en visio
pardon monsieur le ministre je ne savais
pas qu'il y avait aussi des personnes
qui se trouvaient en visio donc
président de site et cités remarquable
de France Monsieur Gilles Alglave
Président c'est ça Alglave président de
maison paysanne de France voilà nous
accueillons à l'instant monsieur Guirec
à rang que je viens juste présenter mais
nous venons juste de commencer
l'audition ne vous inquiétez pas
monsieur Christophe Blanchard Dignac qui
est président de la Fédération
patrimoine environnement monsieur Julien
Lacaze président de l'association site
et monuments Monsieur Christian Laporte
qui est président de l'association des
architectes du patrimoine Monsieur
Raphaël Gastebois qui est vice-président
de l'association vieille maison
française
et enfin Monsieur Marc louai et Gabriel
de Beauregard qui sont tous les deux
architectes des bâtiments de France
voilà je pense n'avoir oublié personne
autour de cette table peut-être
monsieur qui est à côté de Monsieur
Tréguier
voilà donc je si vous étiez amené à
prendre la parole ce qui n'est pas
impossible mais à ce moment là il faudra
bien sûr que vous prêtiez serment comme
chacun des personnes qui vont qui vont
être auditionnées dans quelques instants
donc Mesdames et Messieurs la protection
du bâti ancien et notamment des
bâtiments classés à l'heure de
l'accélération de la Rénovation
Énergétique est une question
fondamentale particulièrement chère à
notre collègue Sabine dragsler qui est
sénatrice du Haut-Rhin mais aussi bien
sûr à chacun d'entre nous rénover des
bâtiments anciens à caractère
patrimonial coûte plus cher et pose des
questions de mode de financement la
prise en compte des enjeux de patrimoine
dans la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments implique également des
approches spécifiques en termes de
cadres juridique d'ingénierie de méthode
d'accompagnement mais aussi de formation
à ce titre le bâti patrimonial étant
soumis toute une série de contraintes
singulières il convient de les traduire
dans les objectifs et dans les moyens de
nos politiques de rénovation il semble
donc que des efforts restent à fournir
et qu'il nous faut aller plus loin afin
de mieux prendre en charge ces enjeux il
vous revient d'éclairer notre commission
sur les voies et les moyens des
évolutions nécessaires dans quelle
mesure les enjeux du bâti ancien
notamment patrimonial sont intégrés au
sein des politiques publiques de la
rénovation énergétique comment de
manière générale prendre en compte les
spécificités du bâti ancien
particulièrement des monuments
historiques classés ou inscrits mais
aussi des secteurs sauvegardés et des
sites patrimoniaux remarquables les
acteurs des politiques publiques de
rénovation énergétique qu'il s'agisse
d'administrations des collectivités des
entreprises ont-ils selon vous pris la
mesure de tous ces enjeux
quelles disposition spécifique faut-il
envisager quel défi juridique financier
et technique se posent que pensez-vous
par exemple des conditions de mise en
œuvre de ma prime rénove des certificats
d'économie d'énergie et du dispositif
mon accompagnateur rénove selon vous
comment les enjeux du patrimoine bâti
pourrait être mieux intégré à la
conception de ces dispositifs comment en
bref mieux prendre en compte les
problématiques de bâtie anciens et de
patrimoine des politiques publiques de
la rénovation énergétique et par
ailleurs est-ce que notre pays dispose
des filières professionnelles capables
de répondre à ce besoin qu'il s'agisse
des artisans ou des matériaux adaptés
voilà en quelques minutes déjà retracées
un certain nombre de questions
auxquelles vous allez je l'espère vous
soumettre et nous apporter vos
réflexions et votre expertise mais avant
de vous laisser la parole pour les
propos introductifs et ensuite monsieur
le rapporteur pourra bien sûr vous poser
un certain nombre de questions
complémentaires ainsi que nos collègues
qui assistent à l'audition il m'a
appartient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu
qui sera publié je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros à
100000 euros d'amende
la raison pour laquelle je vous invite
tour à tour à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité a
levé la main droite et à dire je le jure
on va commencer par vous monsieur et
ensuite à tour de rôle si vous voulez
bien se prêter à cet exercice de
formalisme mais qui est obligatoire
je lève la main droite et je dis je le
jure
[Musique]
je le jure
je
le jure
je le jure
monsieur le ministre est-ce qu'on peut
vous solliciter
bien sûr et je le jure aussi tout en
vous priant l'excuser ma distance
aujourd'hui mais je ne pouvais
absolument pas faire autrement
on vous entende très bien et donc voilà
on sera heureux de d'avoir votre réponse
à un certain nombre de ces questions
combien importante alors je ne sais pas
oui monsieur le ministre je suis
accompagné par un de nos conseillers
est-ce qu'il est autorisé à intervenir
ou est-ce que il ne l'est pas alors il
est bien sûr autorisé à intervenir mais
à partir du moment où il intervient il
faut préalablement qu'il prête serment
conseiller qui vont partir de notre
groupe d'experts on va lui demander de
bien vouloir se prêter à la même
formalisme
merci beaucoup voilà donc nous avons
donc passé ces moments de formalisme et
donc nous allons vous laisser la parole
alors je ne sais pas
comment
ah c'est vous qui commencez
mais voilà
mes soigner me dit que c'est vous qui
commencez alors commencez pas de souci
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
je vais commencer un peu à froid mais
vous avez chauffé déjà l'atmosphère en
nous donnant les grands axes du sujet
moi je vais très simple j'ai simplement
dire que la transition écologique est
une des priorités du Ministère de la
Culture une des priorités ça va de soi
depuis l'installation du nouveau
gouvernement en mai dernier et d'autant
plus que la ministre de la Culture a
fait de cette priorité de la transition
écologique une de ses propres priorités
donc le ministère de la Culture depuis
il est mobilisé déjà depuis longtemps
mais politiquement il est très mobilisé
sur cette transition écologique depuis
un an avec un travail en cours qui
consiste à élaborer ce qu'on appelle une
feuille une feuille de route écologique
de la transition écologique qui va
mobiliser l'ensemble des secteurs le
secteur du patrimoine dont j'ai la
responsabilité mais aussi la création
mais aussi
donc ça dans quelques semaines on rendra
public cette feuille de route mais juste
cette priorité est une priorité du
ministère elle doit évidemment se
concilier avec d'autres priorités et
celles que moi je porte comme directeur
général des patrimoine et d'architecture
c'est évidemment la protection du
patrimoine et donc tout est à faire
d'équilibre on le sait entre dans le
domaine de la politique des politiques
publiques
cet équilibre il est possible nous
semble-t-il et c'est un message que je
voudrais délivrer comme en la montré et
j'en parlais avec Sabine stressler pour
ce qui est des panneaux photovoltaïques
qui ont été au cœur de la loi qu'on
appelle à père je crois accélération
pour l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables
parce que on a montré cette occasion que
pour éviter la tentation de
de renoncer à la vie conforme des ABS on
a été capable de mettre au point avec le
ministère de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des territoires avec le
ministère chargé de l'énergie une
instruction commune pour donner des
orientations aux ABS sur le terrain pour
ne pas diriger tous évidemment de Paris
on peut pas tout régler c'est évidemment
des cas qui doivent être réglés sur le
terrain mais en même temps donner des
directives et au fond lâcher une forme
de l'Est sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques dans les zones qui
doivent être protégées mais en même
temps en donnant des directives strictes
pour qu'on nos paysages ne soient pas
envahis par ces panneaux et qui
dégradent évidemment à terme l'ensemble
de nos centres villes donc on a réussi
avec cette instruction qui est du 9
décembre 2022 a montré que les trois
ministères étaient capables de
travailler ensemble pour donner des
directives sur le terrain
c'est ce qui me rend relativement
confiant mais il y a un énorme travail à
faire et vous l'avez très bien dit sur
ce qui nous reste à faire avec le
ministère de la transition écologique on
part quand même de dans ce domaine là la
rénovation
thermique l'isolation thermique on part
quand même de plus loin on part de plus
loin parce que le ministère de la
culture n'a pas été associé à
l'élaboration du DPE il n'a pas été
associé à l'élaboration du DPE et
aujourd'hui le DPE est devenu opposable
quand il était juste un élément de
référence bon c'était pas forcément
gravissime mais aujourd'hui il est de
plus en plus opposable il va l'être
encore plus dans les temps qui viennent
alors
on part de plus loin il faut donc
travailler avec nos collègues de la
transition écologique il y a quand même
un élément important qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que ce DPE puisqu'il est au
cœur du sujet ne s'applique pas au
monument historiques ça c'est clair mais
il s'applique aux abords des monuments
historiques dans les secteurs
patrimoniaux remarquables dans les
bâtiments qui sont protégés au-dessus du
PLU il s'applique au bâtiment qui sont
labellisés architecture contemporaine
remarquable et puis plus largement au
bâti anciens que en général on situe
avant 48 donc il y a quand même un
énorme champ sur lequel il est
applicable pour ce qui est des des zones
protégées on considère que qui relève de
notre responsabilité protection du
patrimoine c'est 30% des logements donc
c'est quand même tout à fait
considérable alors pour avancer sur ce
terrain et trouver le fameux équilibre
que j'évoquais et qui n'est pas encore
atteint on a eu des réunions avec nos
collègues de la transition ministère de
la transition et écologique plusieurs en
22 il y en a une tout récemment qui
s'est tenue en mai on en parlait avec
Madame
puisqu'elle a eu tout simplement la
semaine dernière avec beaucoup d'acteurs
du patrimoine et nos collègues quelles
sont les attentes du ministère de la
Culture je vais être trop long je pense
qu'elles doivent recouper une partie de
celle des acteurs qui sont aujourd'hui
réunis ce qu'on voudrait nous c'est
que le DPE soit modifié pour prendre en
compte
une nouvelle grille d'analyse qui
prennent en compte le bâti et ses
caractéristiques propres on considère
que il faut une approche globale et que
ce qui est fait aujourd'hui est trop
mécanique trop automatique et que on ne
prend pas les caractéristiques propres
du bâtiment ancien c'est-à-dire son
système constructif les matériaux
l'inertie de ces bâtiments les usages
c'est extrêmement important quand on
travaille sur un logement ou un immeuble
de prendre en compte ces usages qui sont
pas du tout les mêmes selon
les bâtiments
donc vraiment le souhait de travailler
sur le DPE deuxième axe on voudrait
travailler sur les diagnostiqueurs la
formation des diagnostiqueurs la manière
dont ils approchent les sujets
mieux diffuser la méthodologie du DPE
adapté au bâtiment ancien travail sur
l'offre de formation il y a un deuxième
bloc de
souhaits du ministère de la Culture qui
sont plus que des souhaits c'est une
discussion interministérielle travailler
sur les diagnostiqueurs et enfin
troisième élément
revoir les systèmes financiers quel
qu'il soit défiscalisations
subventions prix bien à des quantités
vous en avez cité certains pour que ils
prennent en compte le bâti ancien ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et ce qu'on
observe c'est que finalement on donne de
l'argent c'est un petit peu le principe
de la rue donne de l'argent pour
détruire et on en donne pas pour
réhabiliter un petit peu la même chose
dans ces systèmes de
d'isolation thermique on donne de
l'argent pour faire des VMC pour faire
de l'isolation par l'extérieur alors
qu'on devrait trouver une manière de
faire qui évite ces systèmes là qui sont
anti-écologiques évidemment puisqu'on on
consomme des matériaux qu'on ne devrait
pas consommer et en plus on abîme le
bâti puisque on l'enferme on ne respire
plus enfin je veux pas faire l'article
puisque je pense que d'autres sont plus
qualifiés que moi pour pour le faire
donc voilà où est-ce qu'on en est et je
terminerai par là
on a obtenu de nos collègues je suis
très direct on a obtenu de nos collègues
de l'environnement une ouverture très
nette sur le travail sur les
diagnostiqueurs oui on va pouvoir
travailler à la formation des
diagnostiqueurs les questions qui leur
seront posées sur le bâti ancien seront
rédigés par nous donc ministère de la
Culture va être présent dans cette dans
ce dispositif on va travailler aux
formations des gens qui travaillent sur
le bâti ancien c'était un gros acquis
qui date il y a quelques jours mais
cette affaire encore une ouverture sur
tous les dispositifs financiers pour y
travailler ensemble donc trouver une
adaptation de ces dispositifs financiers
pour qu'ils intègrent notre
préoccupation du bâti ancien ce qui
reste encore à gagner peut-être que les
débats au Sénat permettront d'avancer
sur ce terrain et la révision du DPE
pour que il intègre davantage les
préoccupations concernant le bâti ancien
et à tout dernier mot pour dire que moi
j'ai plutôt bon espoir d'abord parce que
ici on y travaille on y travaille avec
tous ceux qui sont aujourd'hui réunis et
puis aussi il y a une faux un fond de
tableau
international je dirais européen qui
devrait nous pousser dans cette
direction on en parlait aussi avec la
sénatrice il y a la révision en cours de
la norme européenne qui est portée par
le Conseil européen de la normalisation
il y a des travaux menés par l'AFNOR en
France qui qui intègre ce bâtit ancien
donc on nous on participe très très fort
à ces groupes de travail et puis au
niveau de la Commission européenne il y
a une directive celle qui vise la
performance énergétique des bâtiments
qui ouvrent vraiment très largement la
possibilité de tenir compte du bâti
ancien pour déroger à l'automaticité de
l'application du DPE qui est
complètement inadéquat pour ce qui est
de des bâtiments qui nous intéressent
voilà donc on est au début d'un
processus on a encore quelques semaines
à moi année pour avancer et il faut
vraiment le faire en partenariat et
encore une fois ce qu'on a réussi à
faire sur les panneaux photovoltaïques
avec d'ailleurs l'appui très fort du
Sénat et qui a contre carré la tentative
de de mettre à bas la vie conforme de
l'ABF dans ces secteurs nous donne
plutôt espoir qu'on devrait pouvoir y
arriver merci de votre attention
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Directeur
Général alors madame la présidente
Françoise Gatel merci madame la
Présidente merci monsieur le rapporteur
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier au
nom de notre association qui regroupe
dans la France métropolitaine un peu
plus de 230 communes qui ont la
particularité de petite parce que la
population maximum est de 6000 habitants
et d'avoir eu un moment de leur histoire
une fonction de centralité qui peut être
économique administrative ou religieuse
comme l'expliquera mon collègue mère de
Tréguier grecaron qui est à côté de moi
je veux vraiment vous remercier
de enfin de porter autant d'intérêt à la
question du patrimoine et de la
transition écologique parce qu'on a
parfois l'impression qu'il s'agit de
deux mondes qui signent ou parfois
innomique et je sais le travail que
conduit notre collègue Sandrine
éclair là-dessus d'abord un élément de
contexte je pense que la transition
écologique elle doit s'inscrire dans un
projet de développement durable et non
petite idée caractères on la prétention
d'avoir inventé le développement durable
ou le concept de ville durable avant
même qu'il ne devienne à la mode parce
que certaines de nos cités ont un peu
plus de 1000 ans et ont su s'adapter à
des usages contemporains en transformant
des bâtiments qui avaient une fonction
que je vais qualifier d'un peu solennel
le voir militaire un usage contemporain
et que l'enjeu est d'importance puisque
parallèlement à la démarche qui est la
vôtre et que à laquelle nous nous
souscrivons parfaitement nous avons un
vrai enjeu dans notre pays de
revitalisation des centres-villes et des
petites centrales notre territoire et
qui font que la ruralité peut exister
parce qu'elle s'appuie sur des centrales
nos petites idées de caractère et que
l'enjeu de la ré du bâti de sa
transformation et du bâti ancien est
aujourd'hui un enjeu majeur dont
l'importance est encore renforcée par le
zéro artificialisation donc merci de
nous inscrire au coeur de vos
préoccupations alors quelques quelques
éléments d'abord nous sommes confrontés
ici mais comme dans beaucoup de sujets à
une pensée en silo donc on s'occupe de
la transition
écologique et de la rénovation
énergétique en prenant en compte
essentiellement ce que j'appellerai un
patrimoine un peu moderne auquel on
vient appliquer des méthodes qui sont un
peu comment dire
uniforme sans prendre en considération
ce que vous avez dit c'est-à-dire des
éléments techniques c'est-à-dire qu'en
matière de construction il y a des
compatibilités de matériaux ou des
incompatibilités qui peuvent générer de
graves maladies de graves détérioration
d'un patrimoine donc ça c'est un élément
extrêmement important et nous avons des
exigences qui sont parfois incompatibles
je donnerai l'exemple d'une de nos
concitoyens qui explique que quand elle
a dû refaire ses ouvertures à la dû
faire appel à un artisan c'est-à-dire
faire du sur-mesure et qu'elle a été
incapable de fournir un certificat
sortant d'une usine ou d'une grande
marque puisque c'est
ces ouvertures faites sur mesure ne
correspondait pas à une norme qu'il
était facile pour un banquier ou un
organisme qui vous prête de l'argent
d'authentifier donc ça c'est une vraie
difficulté ensuite je pense que nous
avons nécessité de rendre compatible
l'usage vous l'avez dit mais aussi cette
transformation qui représente un coup
très conséquent on sait que si on veut
encourager aussi des propriétaires
privés à rénover de l'habitat en anciens
il y a un vrai sujet qui est la capacité
à faire puisque on sait que la
rénovation de bâti ancien est beaucoup
plus coûteuse ce qui pose la question
voulait très bien dit Madame la
président et je crois que c'est un enjeu
majeur de l'existence de filière de
matériaux je donnerai un exemple dans
mon interco on a voulu faire un bâtiment
avec du béton de champ il y a déjà fort
longtemps et on n'a pas pu parce que
aucune assurance n'acceptait d'assurer
le bâtiment contre le feu alors même
qu'il y avait eu des tas de de
démonstration et d'études qui montrait
la capacité
la capacité de résistance donc je pense
que on a un vrai sujet on a aussi un
sujet autour de la multiplication des
interlocuteurs aujourd'hui
dans certaines de nos collectivités des
propriétaires qui sont parfois des
petits propriétaires se retrouvent
confrontés un grand nombre d'Inter ils
sont un peu perdus donc il y a un vrai
sujet d'ingénierie et de capacité à
faire alors que nous travaillons très
bien avec les architectes des bâtiments
de France et moi je veux les saluer
parce que si les architectes de
bâtiments de France n'avaient pas été là
nous aurions aujourd'hui des centres
villes complètement
on aurait dit qui aurait disparu et qui
ont été remplacés par des constructions
qui n'étaient pas forcément écologique
qui avait juste l'avantage d'être
extrêmement donc vraiment essayez de
travailler pour que des entreprises
puissent s'intéresser au marché du bâti
ancien parce que je pense que si les
produits sont extrêmement chers parce
que ce bâti ancien représente une niche
une petite niche et que les industriels
préfèrent des marchés de masse et qu'il
y a je pense aussi un encouragement à
avoir une formation à faire auprès des
artisans qui doivent mettre en œuvre des
matériaux cette mise en plus compliqué
elle est plus cher mais elle est surtout
plus longue donc on a parfois un gâchis
parce que on ne sait pas faire ou il y a
un enjeu de masse et de nécessité de
productivité qui fait que
l'exigence du bâti ancien par fois un
peu déroutante et en tout cas on ne s'y
attache pas suffisamment et puis je
pense que il faut que l'on ait un
accompagnement vous l'avez dit Monsieur
le Directeur du ministère de la Culture
associée au ministère de la transition
écologique avec je pense des fédérations
professionnelles pour que les ABS
eux-mêmes sur le terrain ne se retrouve
pas confrontés à des exigences que
j'entends et je respecte mais parfois
d'organismes comme la Bréal ou que
sais-je qui impose des normes qui sont
juste incompatibles avec le respect et
l'inscription dans des temps modernes du
bâti du bâti ancien donc il faut
vraiment qu'on arrive à élaborer une
sorte de charte qui rassure et qui rend
possible les choses au niveau du
territoire sachant je l'ai dit que
beaucoup de convictions que l'on voit
que toutes les constructions anciennes
et de caractères elles avaient le mérite
d'être assez vertueux parce qu'elles
étaient faites dans le cadre de circuits
courts avec des matériaux
on va dire du site est très souvent elle
prenait au compte de leur environnement
parce que je prendrai l'exemple de
maison de pêcheurs en Bretagne les
grandes fenêtres et les grandes
ouvertures que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui n'existait pas tout
simplement s'il y avait des phénomènes
de météo qui faisaient qu'on
construisait en s'adaptant donc voilà ce
que je voulais dire un peu en
introduction mais encore une fois
vraiment il faut qu'on sensibilise
l'ensemble des acteurs à l'enjeu de ce
que représente le patrimoine ancien
parce que
je pense qu'il est source de vitalité de
dynamisme pour beaucoup de nos
territoires et que c'est aussi un
élément de fierté pour des habitants et
je pense que cela participe d'une
philosophie de développement durable
extrêmement compatible avec la
rénovation énergétique et sans doute que
mon collègue Yaman vous donnera quelques
exemples notamment aussi sur l'enjeu
d'accompagnement financier alors
Monsieur le Maire est-ce que vous voulez
d'ores et déjà compléter les propos de
madame la Présidente merci madame la
Présidente comment passer derrière la
présidence parce que finalement elle a
déjà tout dit ou beaucoup dit les uns
les autres je me permettrais peut-être
de refaire aussi quelques ajouts est-ce
que j'ai pu entendre oui effectivement
je suis je souscris à cette idée qui ne
faut pas opposer transition écologique
et patrimoine parce que s'il y a bien un
bâti qui est d'intérêt écologique et
depuis toujours c'est bien le bâti
ancien donc ça c'est quelque chose
d'important qu'il faut dire et rappeler
la présidente m'a soufflé l'image du
circuit court quand vous posez la
question des matériaux et bien ils sont
adaptés aussi à la réalité d'un
territoire il suffit d'observer nos
paysages ils sont précieux y compris les
paysages urbains nous voyons bien que
nous n'avons pas construit n'importe
quoi n'importe où la présidente la bien
rappelé sur les fenêtres effectivement
aujourd'hui on a l'impression qu'on va
dans les painty les maisons de bord de
mer en Bretagne on va créer des
ouvertures côtérite côté mer pour avoir
la vue sauf que parfois la vue elle est
en plein Nord notamment sur la côte de
la Manche donc effectivement il y a un
compatibilité je voudrais revenir par
contre sur un certain nombre de choses
que Monsieur le Directeur Général vous
avez abordé tout à l'heure c'est la
question des outils pour mesurer
effectivement aujourd'hui force cette
constater que les outils ne sont pas à
la hauteur du bâti ancien
les DPE tels qu'ils ont été conçus ne
donnent pas une vision claire net et
précise de ce qui peut être apporté ça
c'est un vrai drame on ne mesure pas
correctement aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
faire premier point et deuxième point
surtout les réponses qui sont apportées
sur la base d'outils qui sont caducs
sont des réponses catastrophiques pour
le bâti puisque aujourd'hui on a
beaucoup parlé effectivement notamment
des ite mais lorsque vous empêchez une
maison de respirer je rappelle que le
bâti ancien c'est un il est vivant il
travaille au fur et à mesure de l'année
il s'adapte aussi aux conditions météo
et il résiste plus plutôt pas mal à ces
phénomènes qui deviennent de moins en
moins épisodiques mais réguliers donc
quand vous allez aujourd'hui appliquer
des réponses modernes sur du bâti ancien
bien forcément vous avez un certain
nombre de bombes à retardements qui vont
éclater d'ici peu je me permettrai aussi
vous me direz si je suis trop long et je
pourrais vous en donner davantage après
si vous le souhaitez mais vous donnez un
exemple quand vous posiez la question
est-ce que aujourd'hui les aides sont à
la hauteur de ce qu'on attend clairement
non il n'y a pas d'aide aujourd'hui
adaptée au bâti anciens disons-le
clairement et mon propos n'est pas
polémique un exemple
nous nous rendons compte pour qu'il y
ait un confort thermique qui est aussi
des conditions sanitaires propres dans
le bâtillon sien les aides de la NA ne
tiennent pas compte du facteur humidité
ça n'existe pas or aujourd'hui quand
vous avez des murs qui sont remplis
d'humidité les conséquences peuvent être
catastrophiques surtout si vous rajoutez
une surépaisseur donc il n'y a pas
d'aide aujourd'hui et là c'est un vrai
sujet pour lequel nous en tant que
collectivité alors je suis
vice-président aussi d'une agglo qui est
délégataire de l'aide à la pierre en
charge de l'habitat et il a fallu que
nous nous mettions en place des outils
complémentaires qui n'existent pas via
nana mais ça ne suffit pas voilà c'est
un plus pour tenir compte et
effectivement
un autre point si vous motorisez
également c'est la question de
l'auto-rénovation ça aussi c'est un
critère qui mérite d'être regardé de
près notamment dans le bâtiment si on
voit qu'il y a beaucoup de de ménages
qui font l'acquisition dans l'ancien qui
ne peuvent prétendre à des aides de Lana
notamment parce que effectivement mais
il faut passer par une entreprise force
cette constater aujourd'hui que sur le
terrain les entreprises sont débordées
en tout cas sur le territoire qui est le
mien en Bretagne je suppose que ça ne
doit pas être différent ailleurs les
entreprises ont du mal à répondre à la
demande nombreuse et du coup et pour des
raisons aussi de prix il y a aussi un
phénomène aussi du prix de l'immobilier
il faut pas le je vis sur le littoral
breton autant vous dire que le problème
il est extrêmement fort
un certain nombre de ménages aujourd'hui
n'ont pas les moyens effectivement de
faire appel à des entreprises et du coup
de fataux sont exclus des dispositifs
financiers nous au niveau de l'anion
Trégor communauté mon inter mon
agglomération nous avons mis accepter
qu'il y a effectivement des aides
propres de la collectivité locale pour
accompagner ses travaux en
auto-construction en étau
auto-rénovation à partir du moment et ça
c'est essentiel qu'il y a un encadrement
et ça c'est important et c'est un point
que la présidente a rappelé tout à
l'heure nous aujourd'hui nous avons un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes nous avons
depuis plus de 10 ans sur le territoire
du Trégor
un espace français c'était le point info
habitat qui était le guichet unique pour
l'ensemble des habitants pour
effectivement aller poser toutes les
questions qui allaient de trouver un
terrain ou une maison achetée des
conseils juridiques lorsqu'on a un
locataire jusqu'aux accompagnements
financiers et de l'agglo et de l'état
aujourd'hui on est un petit peu inquiet
avec notamment les accompagnateurs mon
accompagnateur rénov qui arrive parce
que ça pose tout un tas de problèmes et
je pense que d'autres sont passés avant
moi et l'ont déjà dit mais nous ce qui
nous inquiète un peu plus c'est qu'on
nous avons cultivé depuis plus de 10 ans
nous avons mis en place une culture de
réseau et nous travaillons ensemble le
l'habitant les collectivités les
services de l'État et je voulais là
aussi tirer mon chapeau aux abbf qui
sont aujourd'hui des facilitateurs dans
nos projets pour reconquérir ou remettre
de la vie dans nos centrales
avec nos conseillers énergies aussi qui
accompagnent et donc nous essayons
d'avoir une culture commune de donner
les clés de compréhension de ce bâti
ancien et nous avons alors nous sommes
peut-être pas très originaux d'autres
territoires le font certainement nous
travaillons aussi avec un certain nombre
de structures à l'échelle de la Bretagne
une association basée à Rennes je pense
à Thiès braise notamment mais il y en a
d'autres et co-construction ou d'autres
qui peuvent apporter un plus à l'usager
et lui expliquer justement lui donner
les clés de ce quel bâti ancien comment
il vit comment il travaille comment on
doit lui apporter des soins et
effectivement c'est ce que nous étions
de mettre en oeuvre et d'apporter j'ai
oublié les artisans pardon excusez moi
le président et nous étions aussi donné
les clés à nos artisans en disant
écoutez ce que vous faites sur une
maison années 60-7080 ça marche
peut-être mais sur ce type de bâtiment
ça ne marche pas et donc nous mettons en
place ces outils et notre crainte
aujourd'hui elle est très simple par
rapport à mon accompagnateur André note
est-ce que cette culture commune que
nous nous forgeons pour apporter les
bonnes solutions sont efficaces ou pas
je me permettrai je m'arrêterai là parce
que sinon je vais monopoliser la parole
mais un dernier point quand même quelque
chose qui n'a pas été dit mais vous avez
entendu moi ce que je déplore à
l'échelle locale c'est l'absence de
vision globale sur les travaux de
rénovation énergétique
voilà et là aussi il faut être très
vigilant parce que on met parfois la
charrue avant les vœux je pourrais
développer si vous le souhaitez
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Maire dans
l'ordre de présentation donc on va
passer la parole à Monsieur le Ministre
mal vie
président bonjour je signale que mon
collaborateur semble avoir été
déconnecté alors
si on peut le reconnecter merci
[Musique]
et ensuite quelques mots sur la
présentation de l'association que je
préside nous travaillons souvent
d'ailleurs avec Françoise Gatel au titre
de son association et d'autres
associations puisque nous avons réuni
dans une association commune les 7
raisons qui s'intéressent au patrimoine
les plus beaux villages de France et si
les caractères les grands sites de
France et j'en passe dans une
association unique qui s'appelle France
patrimoine et territoire d'exception
pour avoir auprès des pouvoirs publics
notamment une audience plus forte c'est
un bel exemple de coopération entre
associations
chacune restant bien entendu dans son
domaine d'indépendance depuis total et
ça m'amène à rester un constat j'ai
entendu avec intérêt Monsieur le
Directeur du patrimoine tout à l'heure
mais je l'entendais monsieur
de la culture
n'avait pas été associée à l'élaboration
du DPE je dois dire que les bras
mentorent je répète depuis des années en
ce qui me concerne faut cesser le
travailler en tube
séparer les différents ministères et
s'il y a un sujet
s'il vous plaît permettez si un sujet
qui appelle l'interministériel c'est
bien celui-là car la ville à
sentrancienne
l'essentiel du petit d'avant 48 il est
bien dans les centres anciens c'est une
vie complexe qui associe un certain
nombre de problèmes qu'on ne peut pas
régler indépendamment les derniers
autres on ne peut pas régler de la
nécessaire maîtrise des dépenses
d'énergie
si on prend en considération d'autres
d'autres phénomènes qui relèvent la
compétence d'autres ministères nous nous
voulons pour la création d'un DPE bâti
ancien
[Musique]
j'avais
participé avant-hier à une réunion de la
commission nationale patrimoine
architecture
le ministère nous a effectivement
annoncé des avancées et sa volonté
d'avancer sur le problème du DPE
mais la simple formation
nécessaire meilleure des diagnostiqueurs
n'est pas et ne sera pas suffisante il
faut toucher au DPE il faut aller au
cœur du dispositif qui a été mis en
place pour qu'il puisse prendre en
compte les particularités du bâti ancien
qui n'est pas le même que le bâti des
années des années qui suivent les années
73 74 75 les premières véritables normes
après je promis job pétrolier
et la Bâtie et d'un bâtie plus récent le
bâti ancien c'est 30% du bâti l'habitat
le logement c'est 30% du logement en
France et si on parvient pas
à réhabiliter ce bâti ancien à le
protéger si on ne parvient pas à
l'adapter à nouvelle condition de vie
alors on ira vers une déshérence plus
forte encore des centres anciens et vers
une tentation
en parallèle de construction neuve à
l'extérieur c'est à dire qu'on retombera
sur le problème de
l'imperméabilisation des sols il faut
donc donner vie au centre ancien et au
logement ancien et tenir compte des
particularités alors nous avons essayé
nous le dit je vais pas être trop long
sur le sujet mais nous avons essayé
depuis une petite une petite grande
dizaine d'années à nous intéresser avec
l'association avec cité au sujet en
partenariat plus récemment avec la
banque des territoires
nous avons créé une plateforme Cartier
aussi un quartier durable on a édité un
ouvrage d'ailleurs sur le même thème
avec le cinéma avec maison paysanne de
France avec l'école d'architecture de
Toulouse nous sommes co-fondateurs du
crébat qui est un centre de ressources
pour le réhabilitation responsable du
bâti ancien bref notre association
s'intéresse au sujet depuis maintenant
plus de plus plus de 10 ans mais
la philosophie c'est de prendre en
compte l'intégralité des problèmes dans
le logement et dans le bâtir ancien
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
aussi quelques réserves à l'égard de la
prime de la prime rénove
qui elle intervient
en réalité nous avons de bons
dispositifs et nous avons les moyens
financiers
[Musique]
l'engagement public entre l'État et les
collectivités locales est assez
considérable aujourd'hui mais quand on
évoque la prime rénov qui est un bon
dispositif on évoque qu'une partie du
problème c'est à dire qu'on va
intervenir pour subventionner
un objet un projet
une pompe à chaleur mais sans se soucier
du reste du bâtiment et de savoir si
cette pompe à chaleur est efficace ou
n'est pas efficace ou en tout cas si son
efficacité n'est pas réduite parce que
le bâtiment lui est une est une passoire
thermique donc politique globale est
prise en considération des
particularités du petit du petit ancien
ça nous semble être au coeur des
dispositifs bien entendu il faut la
formation les diagnostiqueurs mais quand
on sait qu'un diagnostic se paye entre
80 et 120 ou 130 euros on voit bien que
s'il n'y a pas derrière le diagnostic
une refonte ou une révision des critères
on en sortira pas
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre donc
puisque vous l'avez cité puis il arrive
dans l'ordre de présentation je laisse
la parole à Monsieur Alglave président
de maison paysanne de France
mettez votre micro s'il vous plaît
monsieur j'avais envoyé une photo est-ce
qu'on pourrait l'approcher pour
introduire mon propos
le choc des photos pour appuyer le poids
des mots reprendre l'expression
consacrée voilà c'est une c'est une
photo qui illustrer notre alerte que
nous avons souhaité lancer à l'occasion
du Salon International du Patrimoine
culturel à Paris
alerte qui visiblement a été entendu
notre appel a été beaucoup relayée
commentée discuter et nous en sommes
très contents alors il y a une deuxième
photo qui va avec celle-ci qui montre
comment on a effacé avec la notion de ce
DPE
voilà la valeur patrimoniale du bâti dit
ancien alors qu'est-ce que c'est que le
bâti ancien c'est important de le dire
parce que dans la sémantique aujourd'hui
il semblerait qu'on ne nomme pas cette
catégorie de bâti qui existe qui est
définie de façon officielle par la
statistique française de lycée qui a
intégré la date de 48 il y a un avant il
y a un après avant 48 vous l'avez dit
les uns et les autres c'est une
architecture profondément écologique qui
reprend les notions du développement
durable du local de l'économie de moyen
faire avec ce qu'on a ce passé quand on
en a pas la maison sort du sol elle est
le reflet du paysage elle est
véritablement symbiose avec son
environnement ce qui n'est pas le cas on
va dire dans l'architecture qui va
suivre après 48 on va passer d'une
architecture on va dire de tradition
avec des savoir-faire qui aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs pose problème on va parler de
la formation ils sont plus transmis
c'est ça aussi le problème et avec des
matériaux qui n'ont plus du tout
disais tout à l'heure montre que leur
cette maison là qui est une maison
patrimoniale connue dans l'Oise où
j'habite c'est le propriétaire un des
propriétaires parce que malheureusement
cette maison il y a deux propriétaires
donc c'est difficile à gérer une façade
qui présente une unité quand il y a deux
propriétaires il faut qu'il s'entende or
il y en a un qui celui de gauche a été
séduit par l'appel de l'isolation à 1
euro et vous voyez les faits on lui a
certainement vanté que ça n'allait rien
lui coûter forcément on a isolé donc
cette façade en pan de bois magnifique
avec des plaques de polystyrène revêtu
d'un enduit bien étanche et ça ça façade
sa partie est devenue selon la
sémantique actuelle un logement décent
probablement c'est comme ça qu'on le
définit et à côté le bâtiment qui reste
dans son état originel avec sa structure
qui est faite pour être vue avec ses
beaux assemblages
symboliques en plus il y a des fastica
il y a tout un tas de choses dans la
symbolique du pont de bois
et bien on va considérer que c'est une
passoire thermique probablement donc
vous voyez qu'il y a un problème
d'approche et de regard sur ce
patrimoine qui n'est pas nommé et ne pas
nommer les choses c'est nier leur
existence c'est ce que je pense moi je
pense que et ça c'est grave parce que on
fait de la formation maison paysanne on
est certifié cardiopie fait de la
formation professionnelle continue parce
que c'est c'est un champ c'est un champ
désert vide on ne s'intéresse pas
suffisamment à cela aujourd'hui donc on
a pris le tour par les cornes et bien
que ce ne soit pas notre raison
essentielle d'agir on le fait on a un
pôle de formateur et on forme des
architectes on forme des techniciens on
forme des maçons on forme ce que
finalement les organismes qui ont
vocation à donner cette culture devrait
faire mais ne font pas suffisamment les
gens qui viennent nous voir nous
demandent des listes d'artisans qui
savent faire on aimerait bien en avoir
souvent on a trop de doigts à nos mains
pour leur répondre on n'a pas assez de
voilà de ressources donc la formation
c'est le véritablement au cœur du sujet
réglementation thermique la première
réglementation thermique c'est après le
choc pétrolier de 73 on a commencé à
légiférer pour dire il faut économiser
l'énergie ça coûte cher c'est un c'est
une ressource rare depuis les les choses
se sont on va dire rigidifier par
rapport au réglementations thermiques
nous sommes maintenant dans la R1
réglementation environnementale donc
beaucoup plus élargi en définitive avec
des bilans carbone avec tout un tas de
de bilans qui nous sont demandés qui se
sur rajoutent et surtout l'opposabilité
du DPE qui pose problème parce que
finalement comme les prédécesseurs qui
sont intervenus l'ont dit on met la
charrue avant les boeufs on n'a pas
intégré un certain nombre de complexité
et de subtilité dans le fonctionnement
du bâti qu'on devrait sortir on va dire
de ce DPE qui ne peut pas arriver à
l'apprécier à sa juste valeur et qui va
forcément comme on le voit ici générer
des atteintes au patrimoine commun
puisque c'est du paysage quand qu'on
promène dans dans nos régions on a des
façades qui sont atteintes et je trouve
ça dramatiques de laisser faire cette
dynamique qui n'est pas vertueuse et qui
coûteuse et c'est une atteinte au
patrimoine particulier des privés qui
habitent ces maisons avec en plus une
atteinte au confort qu'on risque de voir
altérer dans ces maisons suite justement
à la perturbation de leurs équilibres
très subtiles qu'on aura perturbé et qui
vont générer des phénomènes d'humidité
moisissures et autres cortèges de
conséquences néfastes quand on fait les
choses comme on les fait donc je pense
que véritablement il faut arrêter
aujourd'hui la machine elle est partie
vers quelque chose qui nous conduit dans
le mur beaucoup de procès déjà sont en
instance d'être présenté devant les
tribunaux puisque l'opposabilité c'est
ça les gens font valoir des préjudices
je pense que la justice a autre chose à
faire que d'être encombré par des des
problèmes qui sont dus à un manque
peut-être de réflexion et d'approche
intelligente on va dire du sujet et donc
nous demandons les associations qui sont
qui se sont réunis ici qu'il y a un
moratoire pour l'application de ce dpe
en attendant qu'on se remette autour de
la table et qu'on réfléchisse tous
autour de la table on a ici un certain
nombre d'associations qui finalement
sont sur la même ligne même approche et
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
apparaît comme nécessaire voilà ce que
je voulais dire nous travaillons avec
les scientifiques pour faire rentrer la
connaissance dans la connaissance du
bâti ancien on va dire dans la modernité
on sait très bien que c'est logique
constructive était des logiques
qui qui était dans l'oralité il n'y
avait pas d'écrit il y a jamais traité
savant sur l'architecture dite
vernaculaire le petit patrimoine comme
on l'appelle
voilà il y a jamais eu d'écrit et c'est
le problème de cette société c'est que
une société qui fonctionne avec des
normes ne peut pas
contenter deux choses qui sont on va
dire dans leur réalité ce n'est plus du
tout l'époque et donc c'est pour ça que
nous avons travaillé pendant 4 ans avec
le ministère de l'écologie à la DHP pour
écrire les guides de bonnes pratiques
dans 6 techniques de Pierre cru en
France c'est c'est guides sont
aujourd'hui accessibles ce n'est pas une
fin en soi le but est que cela devienne
des règles professionnelles de manière à
ce que l'on puisse
élaborer des référentiels de formation
et se mettre à la tâche de former des
maçons de terre puisque en fait ici
c'est sur le matériau clair que l'on
travaille et vous devez savoir qu'il y a
en France aujourd'hui un projet national
terre cru qui est une labellisation du
Gouvernement sur ce matériau qui
apparaît comme une alternative aux
enjeux de notre modernité
difficulté trouver des ressources rareté
des agrégats le sable va devenir aussi
rare que l'eau il y a déjà des trafics
dans certains pays de sable parce que
c'est un matériau qui devient de moins
en moins on va dire présent et
accessible donc là encore et puis
l'industrie du béton on sait très bien
qu'elle les voit disparaître donc la
terre est un matériau qui va rentrer
dans la modernité et ça fait 11000 ans
que l'homme utilise ce matériau pour
construire on a donc une générique qui
existe pour employer un mot moderne sur
ce matériau et en fait dans toutes les
les maisons anciennes du bâti ancien
dont on parle la terre est présente que
ce soit le bois ici avec le remplissage
du hourdis qui est fait en torchis chez
nous que ce soit les maisons en pierre
qui étaient souvent ourdes avec de la
terre en majorité il faut le savoir nous
on a sauvé à Beauvais une petite maison
du 15e siècle on a démonté
bric-à-briques parce qu'elle était
Cédric était hourdé à la terre et
aujourd'hui on va les monter avec un
mortier pur et dur on pourra plus
revenir en arrière la réversibilité
faisait partie des logiques
constructives des anciens et je dis moi
c'est logique constructive devrait être
pour nous des modèles d'écologie ce
qu'elles ne sont pas aujourd'hui
puisqu'on les dans la catégorie des
passoires passoire thermique et souvent
on détruit de l'ancien en disant pour de
mauvaises raisons que c'est pas possible
de restaurer ce n'est plus habitable ça
coûterait trop cher etc ça aussi il va
falloir revoir le sujet le zan fait
partie également d'une décision
vertueuse à condition qu'il s'accompagne
d'incitation non pas à détruire de
l'ancien ce que font aujourd'hui
certains promoteurs pour trouver du
foncier puisqu'ils ne peuvent plus
construire et à perméabilité du sol mais
inciter à réutiliser de l'ancien
pour éviter le gâchis que représente le
fait de faire la table la table rase on
va dire de cette de ces éléments de
culture aussi qui sont des éléments
importants auxquels les gens dans les
Bours et dans les villages sont attachés
donc on est vraiment dans quelque chose
qui peut à mon avis augmenter
l'intérêt pour les citoyens de base de
participer activement à partir de leur
maison et de la façon dont on va les
accompagner à comprendre comment
fonctionne leur maison et comment ils
peuvent dans leur maison améliorer je
parle pas moi d'isolation mais
d'amélioration des performances puisque
les maisons déjà anciennes en ont faut
le dire le l'inertie dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure et dont on parle peu
aujourd'hui
l'inertie c'est la capacité des
matériaux anciens de lutter contre les
transferts de chaleur quand ils sont
importants qui fait 40 degrés à
l'extérieur et bien vous êtes à 24
degrés chez vous pendant au moins 8
heures de la journée parce que les
matériaux ont cette capacité naturelle à
lutter contre les transferts de chaleur
et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
les modes de construction que l'on a on
construit avec des matériaux qui vont
ensuite être comment dirais-je
accompagné par des pompes à chaleur qui
a le vent en poupe parce que ça produit
effectivement de la chaleur mais ça
produit aussi du froid donc finalement
les pompes à chaleur sont intéressantes
aujourd'hui elles vont fonctionner tout
le temps pratiquement il faudrait
peut-être un petit peu réfléchir à
introduire des matériaux ils existent
les matériaux qu'on appelle biosourcés
ou géosourcés qui font aussi partie de
l'innovation qui se fait non pas en
lutte par rapport au passé il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre le passé le présent
mais simplement le passé c'est une
source d'inspiration pour l'avenir c'est
une source d'inspiration pour le présent
aussi et il est en train de se
développer en France on a parlé du chaud
chambre moi je suis un
fervent défenseur de la terre parce que
le bilan carbone de la terre est encore
plus vertueux de la chaux la chose c'est
comme un produit industriel un
sous-produit industriel même si c'est
mieux que le ciment et donc la terre
mélangée avec du chanvre vous mélangez
avec d'autres liant on va dire en
quantité qui vont améliorer les
performances ou qui vont atténuer
l'effet de parois froide dans nos
maisons voilà des solutions qu'il faut
on va dire populariser à tous les
niveaux les professionnels mais aussi le
maître d'ouvrage le propriétaire qui est
démarché au téléphone et qui va signer
le devis parce qu'il sait pas et parce
que c'est incitatif on lui dit ça vous
coûte rien vous voyez c'était vraiment
on pousse au crime donc il faut arrêter
ces chasseurs de primes qui finalement
contribuent à dépenser l'argent public
de façon complètement folle où il faudra
y revenir les procès vont forcément un
moment donné désigner des responsables
ça coûtera très cher il faudra refaire
ce qui a été mal fait il faudra payer
les préjudices et je dis moi il est
temps de dire mettons-nous autour de la
table et faisons en sorte qu'il y ait un
diagnostic int des gens qui tiennent
compte de ce magnifique
paysage que constitue cette architecture
sans architecte il faut le dire quand
même on parle beaucoup d'architecture
aujourd'hui c'est une architecture sans
architecte et véritablement qui est
arrivé à un niveau je dirais moi de
simplicité de perfection authenticité
simplicité et on est vraiment dans
l'écologie aujourd'hui donc voilà moi ce
que je voulais dire je le dis avec
passion parce que à maison paysanne nous
sommes des passionnés et je pense que
nous allons essayer de continuer à
entraîner dans notre passion tous ceux
qui sont dans cette
dynamique aujourd'hui parce que c'est
nécessaire voilà ce que je voulais dire
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président de
vos propos on passe à monsieur le
Président de la Fédération patrimoine
environnement
oui merci madame la Présidente comme
notre nom l'indique nous occupons de
conjuguer patrimoine et environnement
c'est l'objet de cette audition je
voulais vous remercier infiniment de
nous donner la parole
nous permettrons de vous adresser dès
demain le document est pratiquement prêt
nos préconisations sur ce sujet 16
préconisations qui sont le résultat du
travail en commun des 7 grandes
associations du patrimoine de
l'Association des architectes des
bâtiments de France et de l'association
des architectes du patrimoine
donc c'est le patrimoine ancien le bâti
ancien c'est pas uniquement les
monuments historiques les monuments
classés protégés 45 000 dont on parle je
sais pas qui pourrait avoir l'idée de
leur appliquer le le DPE actuel mais
c'est ce serait une un crime une hérésie
nous parlons de 10 millions de logements
en France et aujourd'hui c'est 10
millions de logements sont en cette
sinistré parce que on n'a pas pris on a
mis on a fait les choses à l'envers on
n'a pas mis le mystère de la culture au
centre du dispositif on a tout de même
extraordinaire d'entendre nous savons
que le DPE a été établi sans consulter
sans même associer le ministère de la
Culture tout de même si on a un
ministère qui est qui se préoccupe du
bâti ancien c'est tout de même le
ministère qui est en charge du
patrimoine du patrimoine se résume pas
au monument historiques qu'ils en sont
la partie la plus étincelante mais les
paysages ce qui fait le charme de
Deauville de nos villes moyennes ce qui
fait le ce qui va permettre la
revitalisation des centres-villes des
c'est tout de même ce que nous enlégué
des générations et ce patrimoine il a
fait la preuve de sa durabilité donc
nous parlons de 10 millions de logements
qui sont en train d'être ou maison qui
sont en train d'être sinistrés voilà le
sujet donc la première des choses
c'est pas un sujet technique c'est un
sujet politique c'est pour ça que nous
sommes au bon endroit et nous remercions
il faut arrêter ce train fou qui va
rentrer dans le mur et il faut
maintenant repartir sur une bonne base
et les bonnes bases c'est d'avoir des
outils bien sûr mais c'est pas c'est une
vision c'est un autre faut changer de
paradigme une maison ancienne un
logement ancien on part d'une vision
globale on part pas de l'outil on parle
pas de tuyauterie on part d'une vision
globale il y a des architectes ici
présents de très haut niveau ils vont
pouvoir parler beaucoup plus savamment
que que moi que moi du sujet
repartir sur de bonnes bases avec le
ministère de la Culture en chef de fil
avec associé bien sûr ministère de la
transition écologique et il faut donc
arrêter le DPE tel qu'il est pour le
bâtiment pour le bâtir ancien parce que
ce qu'on est en train de faire c'est une
catastrophe donc il faut arrêter la
catastrophe
on parle souvent j'entends dire ça coûte
cher la rénovation si on résonne en
terme de bilan écologique et pas
économique ce n'est pas vrai c'est la
c'est la rénovation telle qu'elle est
faite à base de produits industriels qui
est une vraie catastrophe écologique le
bon plan comme on dit de nos jours le
bon plan environnemental c'est de faire
de la rénovation de bâtir anciens c'est
le long plan voilà le sujet c'est qu'il
faut que tout le monde en soit convaincu
qu'il y ait toutes les formations
requises qui est les compétences que que
ceux qui conseillent soient là que les
ressources publiques soient beaucoup
mieux fléchées j'étais directeur du
budget il y a fort longtemps je peux
vous dire l'argent public il est
suffisant simplement il est mal orienté
il encourage qui est mauvais et il
n'encourage pas ce qui est bon pour la
durabilité donc nous c'est ce qu'on
demande maintenant c'est que les choses
soient remises à l'endroit c'est-à-dire
qu'on est reconnaissent la spécificité
du ancien qu'on reconnaisse sa
durabilité le bâti ancien par définition
il dure parce il a connu même plusieurs
vies dans sa dans sa vie et nous
espérons qu'il va en connaître plusieurs
mais si on le isole avec du polystyrène
par l'extérieur et bien je crois qu'il
va pas vivre très longtemps et c'est ça
le sujet qui nous préoccupe et au-delà
de du côté esthétique il y a tout le
côté attractivité de nos territoires et
tout de même une des grandes richesses
de la France il y a beaucoup à faire en
matière de formation La formation des
diagnostiqueurs bien sûr mais la
formation de tout le monde a commencé
par même celle des architectes voilà il
y a beaucoup de formations beaucoup
d'informations donc 16 préconisations
que nous vous adresserons dès demain et
j'arrête de parler parce que il y a
beaucoup de monde qui doit parler
notamment mon voisin mais aussi les
architectes il faut tout de même donner
la parole aux architectes parce qu'il y
a des personnes qui ont une vision
globale d'un bâtiment ce sont tout de
même les AR est passé partir de l'outil
pour aller à l'essentiel c'est pas la
bonne méthode il faut partir de
l'essentiel et ensuite on va aux outils
merci alors on va écouter maintenant
monsieur Julien Lacaze président de
l'association site et monument je vous
remercie madame le présidente alors je
représente ici une association qui est
très ancienne puisqu'elle a été fondée
en 1901 qui est une association qui est
donc agréée pour la protection de
l'environnement c'est c'est important de
le dire et qui est une association
généraliste c'est à dire qui défend la
fois les paysages le bâti et le mobilier
et parmi toutes les menaces que nous
rencontrons le paysage qui peut être
parasitée par des installations
industrielles comme des éoliennes ou
mobilier qui peut être dispersés et bien
la plus grave des menaces et
probablement celle qui touche la
rénovation thermique du bâti parce que
dans les deux cas que je viens de citer
sont des choses qui sont plus ou moins
facilement réversible une éolienne on
pourra un jour l'enlever du mobilier on
pourra éventuellement le regrouper le
retrouver le racheter le bâti lorsqu'il
est mal isolé il est détruit donc c'est
nous nous plaçons vraiment cette
question vraiment au devant de toutes
nos préoccupations alors très
concrètement un bâti ancien ou
patrimonial ou de petits patrimoine de
petits patrimoine et quelque chose qui
est fragile ce qui se passe de manière
très concrète c'est qu'on commence par
lui retirer ces menuiseries on est en
train aujourd'hui et j'aimerais insister
sur ce point de perdre nos portes
anciennes une porte ancienne c'est l'âme
d'une maison il y a des diversités
régionales d'université de richesse
diversité stylistique c'est absolument
passionnant des livres entiers sur les
portes on est en train de perdre ses
portes anciennes ça c'est vraiment un
sujet qui devrait être un sujet de
préoccupation de de tous les ministères
ensuite on va noyer la façade de
ce bâtiment en ayant préalablement
bûcher c'est à dire détruit les
ornements un peu trop saillants pour y
arriver des dalles en polystyrène et
puis pour terminer le l'oeuvre
d'isolation on va pouvoir cacher souvent
les ayant détruit les décors intérieurs
par du placoplatre alors que reste-t-il
de cette maison il ne reste absolument
rien de patrimonial on a un simple
gabarit voilà et c'est ça qu'il faut
absolument essayer de essayer d'éviter
et d'autant que cette menace se conjugue
avec une autre qui est pourtant inspirée
par un bon principe qui est le principe
de la
zéro artificialisation nette alors que
risque-t-il de se passer c'est que ces
maisons qui sont anciennes qui ne
peuvent pas atteindre parfois des
niveaux de performance les niveaux de
performance qu'on leur demande et bien
elles ne vont pas pouvoir être louées
elles vont tout doucement se dégrader et
elles vont finir par être détruites
parce que ce principe de zéro
artificialisation nette demande à ce
qu'on reconstruise la ville sur la ville
elles vont être les premières cibles ces
maisons
ou même qui ont été peut-être mal isolés
de ces de ces promoteurs qui vont s'en
emparer pour pour les pour les détruire
tout ça est vraiment vraiment très très
préoccupant ce qui est ce qui est très
difficile à enrayer c'est cet esprit de
système c'est à dire l'idée que il faut
absolument appliquer un même régime à
tous les bâtiments de France et ça
évidemment c'est très difficile de
lutter contre ça puisqu'il y a le moteur
du urgence et quand on travaille dans
l'urgence et on travaille sans réfléchir
ça c'est absolument terrible et cette
cet esprit de système il conduit à une
nouvelle insalubrité c'est à dire que
ces maisons qui sont revêtues de
plastique de PVC de polystyrène ce sont
des cocottes minutes et maison paysanne
de France connaît bien ce cette question
quand on vient voir maison paysanne de
France c'est en général parce qu'on a
commencé à faire de nouvelles choses et
la maison se met à dysfonctionner voilà
donc vraiment pensons à cette nouvelle
insalubrité qui va arriver avec avec ces
rénovations inappropriées alors quand
même un espoir un espoir qui me vient
des réseaux sociaux on est assez actif
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment sur
Twitter et bon en promenant dans Paris
je vois comme ça abandonné une fenêtre
qui devait être d'époque d'époque
Louis-Philippe avec ses carreaux anciens
donc je me dis que c'est un sujet très
très difficile qui n'intéresse personne
j'ai fait un tweet sur l'abandon de
cette fenêtre comme ça au pied d'un
arbre et ce tweet a fonctionné de
manière extraordinaire donc j'ai été
vraiment surpris de voir que même pour
moi c'était plus difficile un défendre
les croiser anciennes alors que j'adore
ça il y en a quelques-unes quelques
beaux spécimens au Sénat et bien voilà
le grand public est sensible et sensible
assez assez question autre autre autre
[Musique]
autre espoir c'est le précédent du
décret sur les travaux embarqués de 2016
que nous avons réussi tous ensemble nous
ayons beaucoup travaillé à l'époque sur
cette question à justement à faire
évoluer même nous avons obtenu un
nouveau décret alors c'est pas commun
d'obtenir un décret présent Conseil
d'État un nouveau décret que mon conseil
d'État donc les travaux ont marqués ce
sont ces travaux l'idée était de dire
quand il y a des ravalement importants
mais on va en profiter pour rendre
obligatoire l'isolation et bien on a
obtenu à l'occasion de ce nouveau décret
à ce que l'obligation ne pèse que sur
les maisons construites en matériaux
modernes mais c'est-à-dire que toutes
les bâtiments qui sont construits en
matériaux traditionnel soit exemptées de
cette obligation d'isoler en cas de de
ravalement important et ça c'est
vraiment une chose qui est qui peut nous
donner de l'espoir et qui peut aussi
nous donner des un début de critères
c'est à dire comment faire pour
distinguer ce qui est ce qui relève du
bâtir ancien et du bâti du bâti moderne
se décrète 2017 qui est toujours en
application la fée alors justement pour
poursuivre sur ces sur ces sur ces
solutions moi je dirais que pour le
patrimoine c'est à dire les monuments
historiques et puis tous les tous les
sites protégés l'idée qui me semble et
celle de l'autonomie législative c'est à
dire que
ces monuments doivent être régis par
leur propre code et pas par d'autres
codes c'est à dire qu'il faut éviter les
renvois de renvoyer vers des principes
qui sont inappropriés en fait assez
assez bâtiment
et ne pas envoyer notamment comme ça a
été fait dans le cadre de la loi
d'accélération des ENR vers des
principes du code de l'énergie qui vont
tout doucement aboutir à la destruction
de ce patrimoine une notion justement
pour pour essayer de de bien de bien
restaurer ce
patrimoine c'est justement celui de
restauration thermique plutôt que de
rénovation thermique rénovation
thermique c'est quand on casse tout on
refait là c'est la restauration
thermique c'est remettre dans son
fonctionnement originel des bâties
anciens qui souvent ont été perturbés
par une première vague de mauvaises
restauration de mauvaises rénovation
plutôt notamment avec avec du PVC et
puis cette idée donc d'autonomie
législative mais peut-être combiné avec
une acculturation douce ce dont parlait
le directeur général des patrimoines
c'est à dire des circulaires qui
viennent prendre certaines
préoccupations d'autres ministères pour
en douceur en fait les insérer dans dans
le champ du patrimoine mais qui doit
garder son régime d'autonomie
législative et puis enfin pour le bâti
traditionnel et bien là il faut trouver
il faut trouver un critère et le critère
pour moi c'est celui qui a été qui a été
qui a été établi par le nouveau décret
de 2017 sur les travaux embarqués c'est
à dire qu'on va mettre à part les
bâtiments qui sont construits en béton
en ciment en brique industriel et en
métal et cela effectivement on va leur
appliquer un régime exigeant les autres
auront un autre régime qui sera
différent et qui aboutira au même au
même au même résultat et l'idée étant
d'avoir à la fois soit un diagnostic
propre à se bâtir ancien mais aussi un
régime propre donc qui est une
différenciation qu'on essaie d'améliorer
les choses mais par des voies
différentes parvenir à un résultat je
dirais comparable ou semblable voilà
j'en ai terminé merci beaucoup donc on
va passer à Monsieur Christian Laporte
qui est président ah non peut-être oui
Monsieur Christian Laporte vous venez
après vous n'êtes pas dans le même mais
je suis ma liste président de
l'association des architectes du
patrimoine bonjour madame la Présidente
merci de nous donner cette la
possibilité de nous exprimer c'est vrai
que on est toujours content nous les
architectes de pouvoir
quels sont le terrain pouvoir témoigner
des difficultés que l'on rencontre
notamment effectivement en méthode DPE
il y a eu beaucoup de témoignages
beaucoup de choses qui se sont dites
donc théoriquement je devrais avoir on
devrait avoir de moins en moins de
choses à dire tout a été dit autour de
cette table j'allais dire que ce qui
fait consensus aujourd'hui vous l'aurez
compris c'est que l'outil dont on parle
aujourd'hui
montre ses limites c'est carences et je
dirais son inadapte son inadaptation
bâti ancien dans la mesure où on est
tous autour de cette table pour
s'accorder à dire que le bâtir aussi a
un fonctionnement propre et autonome en
tout cas différent du bâti d'après 1948
de fait la législation qui va
s'appliquer alors moi je la mets
j'appellerai pas ça la restauration
énergétique j'ai la même l'amélioration
énergétique et environnementale du bâti
ancien ou du bâti patrimonial mais on va
parler plutôt du bâti patrimonial en ce
qui concerne les architectes du
patrimoine de fait elle doit
effectivement bénéficier de mesures
voilà tout à fait spécifique je dirais
qu'on pourrait même étendre
cette réflexion sur je dirais en règle
générale la réglementation qui
s'applique au bâtir ancien en matière de
de notion de structure de notion de
sécurité de tous ordres on s'aperçoit
que non on est confronté tous les jours
dans la pratique de nos métiers elle a
difficulté et parfois l'inadaptation
quand il faut appliquer ces mesures sur
le bâti patrimonial elle bâtit ancien
quelques quelques réflexions et quelques
je voudrais absolument insister sur des
idées reçues on le débat était posé en
disant comment faire pour que le bâti
patrimonial ne soit pas mis à l'écart de
l'amélioration énergétique que tout le
monde appelle le CBC autour de cette
table je pense qu'on n'est pas il y en a
pas un seul qui dirait qu'il faut pas le
faire simplement c'est plutôt le bâti
c'est plutôt le batterie patrimonial qui
porte en lui-même les germes mais en
tous les cas les recettes de ce qu'il
faut faire puisqu'il est lui-même je
dirais durable depuis qu'il est né
depuis qu'il a été construit donc
attention on a à ne pas j'ai la glable
le redisait tout à l'heure le papier
patrimonial égal pas sur énergétique il
faut absolument
cesser ces idées reçues cette idée reçue
la plupart du temps c'est faux et on a
tellement d'ailleurs stigmatisé autour
de cela que même sur les monuments
historiques et ça c'est quand même aussi
un sujet même si les monuments
historiques dérochent aujourd'hui au DPE
malheureusement nos propriétaires privés
en monument historiques classés inscrits
nous demandent quand même de réfléchir à
mettre en place du double vitrage dans
des menuiseries du 18e siècle ou dans
des dans des voilà dans des châteaux des
fois où c'est juste pas possible de le
faire donc on est confronté de toute
façon nous à la réflexion globale sur
comment faire pour produire moins
d'énergie qui émettent des gaz à effet
de serre y compris dans les monuments
historiques c'est un sujet que dont on
ne peut pas déroger même en monument
historique et on doit réfléchir aussi à
la manière de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique parce que
là aussi il est changement climatiques
on s'en aperçoit aujourd'hui en monument
historique ils sont prégnants au niveau
de la sécheresse et de dessiccation des
sols au niveau des désordre que ça peut
engendrer sur les monuments donc la
réflexion nous on amène depuis très
longtemps au sein de l'association
je rappelle qu'on a on est associé au
krébage je crois que Monsieur le
Ministre la cité tout valeur le centre
de ressources pour la réhabilitation
responsable du bâti ancien est un bel
outil je pense qu'il n'est
malheureusement pas assez doté
aujourd'hui il ne bénéfice pas mon avis
d'une dotation suffisante pour pouvoir
porter sur les réseaux des recettes et
vous allez pas dire j'ai même pas des
recettes mais des idées quant à la
manière d'aborder l'amélioration
énergétique sur le bâtiment ancien on
est partenaire du crébat depuis sa
fondation ont souscrit on participe
également à des formations à l'école de
Chaillot sur l'amélioration énergétique
et environnementale du bâti patrimonial
on s'est saisi à bras le corps de ce
sujet
il faut comprendre qu'aujourd'hui le
caractère vertueux d'intervenir sur le
bâti ancien de toute façon il l'est de
fait puisque le bâti ancien c'est l'art
de la réhabilitation
c'est l'art du geste
parcimonieux du geste sur mesure et je
m'oppose un peu à ce que vous avez dit
Madame Gatel tout à l'heure
attention de ne pas non plus
effectivement dire que la rénovation ou
la transformation du bâti ancien coûte
plus cher je crois que c'est pas si vrai
que ça et c'est même l'inverse je pense
que quand on fait appel à une maîtrise
d'oeuvre compétente spécialisée qui sait
qui connaît le sujet dont elle parle
elle s'est ciblée effectivement les
points sur lesquels on va apporter des
éléments d'amélioration et justement de
manière ciblée on va pas généraliser un
faut tout refaire il faut tout refaire
six photos refaire ça je crois que c'est
important de le dire on va être là on va
être en capacité de dire
voilà ce qu'il faut faire on va
peut-être changer ça peut-être pas
changer ça mais en tous les cas on sera
probablement sur une démarche
parcimonieuse et minimaliste
l'architecte du patrimoine il aime à
conserver la matière ancienne donc il
est plutôt sur une démarche minimaliste
et pas maximaliste c'est important de le
dire parce que là aussi dans les idées
reçues je pense qu'on se dit toujours oh
là là la restauration ça coûte très cher
de toute façon le simple fait de ne pas
déconstruire et de conserver de Habilité
c'est déjà plus vertueux et c'est déjà
plus économique j'irai après nous on est
en tant que moi je m'exprime aussi en
tant que maître d'oeuvre et puis je
laisserai mes confrères architectes des
bâtiments de France expect également en
complément nous on insiste sur la
qualité du diagnostiqueur parce que
au-delà du fait qu'il faut effectivement
un DPE spécifique on est tous à peu près
d'accord autour de cette table
il faut aussi une qualité du
diagnostiqueur c'est à dire quand on
pose un diagnostic énergétique sur un
bâti ancien ça peut pas être fait par
mon accompagnateur enfin bon nous on
avait en tant que architecte on avait
d'ailleurs signé une pétition quand ce
label est sorti un pharmacien qui
s'approvise diagnostiquaire immobilier
puisqu'on a eu ce genre d'exemple
du Conseil national de l'architecte et
10 000 signatures un tiers des
architectes de France qui s'opposaient à
ses accompagnateurs rénovs n'ont pas en
soi ces personnes là elles font ce
qu'elles peuvent mais elles ne sont pas
formées donc aujourd'hui je pense que
nous on a une théorie par rapport à ça
c'est qu'il faut que les diagnostiqueurs
soient des gens qui connaissent le bâti
ancien pour la plupart qu'il soit
architectes même s'il s'agit
d'intervenir sur des architectures sans
architecte je sais plus qui disait ça
c'est l'architecture sans architecte
peut avoir aussi besoin de mettre
d'oeuvre et je pense que il faut pour
qu'il y ait cette formation il faut
aussi encourager les gens qui font de la
réhabilitation
à ce que leur maîtrise d'oeuvre ne leur
coûte pas trop cher c'est à dire qu'il
faut aussi se poser la question de la
subvention des honoraires de ces
diagnostiqueurs au même titre que l'on
peut effectivement les incitations
fiscales sur ces audits énergétiques il
faut que le coût de la maîtrise d'oeuvre
spécialisée hautement spécialisée pour
ces choses-là soit intégrés à mon avis
je pensais ce serait une donnée très
importante pour encourager une bonne
maîtrise d'euros vous l'avez souligné le
coût d'un diagnostic dépend aujourd'hui
c'est 80 à 120 euros autant te dire
qu'on n'a pas d'outils c'est pas du tout
un outil qui est à la hauteur des enjeux
donc on s'aperçoit bien qu'effectivement
il faut voilà qu'un diagnostic que le
diagnostiqueur soit formé moi je pense
que dans les écoles d'architecture
aujourd'hui et nous on incite au sein de
notre association il faut qu'aujourd'hui
les écoles d'architecture en amont de
l'école de Chaillot dont on est issu
face vraiment des cours de l'art de la
réhabilitation avec ce sujet je dirais
en objective principal à faire en sorte
que ce bâti en soins montre toutes ces
vertus et tout le potentiel qu'il peut
avoir par rapport effectivement
à son comportement
il faut aussi avoir en notion l'aspect
et je m'arrêterai là pour laisser la
parole à mes confrères le temps de
retour carbone vous connaissez tous
cette notion vous en avez tous entendu
parler on balance aujourd'hui on met
beaucoup d'argent dans l'amélioration
énergétique avec toute l'énergie des
crises que ça suppose mais on n'apprécie
pas encore à ça le temps de retour
carbone c'est-à-dire en gros quand
est-ce qu'on est à l'équilibre entre ce
que ça a coûté en termes de production
de gaz à effet de serre quand il a fallu
faire cette restauration et le moment où
ça commençait ça commence à générer des
économies réelles en termes de
production de gaz à effet de serre pour
le bâtiment alors on s'aperçoit que ce
temps-là il est pas si court que ça et
malheureusement on a encore sur des
temps de retour carbone qu'on ne mesure
pas et c'est bien joli de passer une
grande isolation thermique par
l'extérieur mais quand on boit les
matériaux qui sont employés leur impact
carbone pour le coup et puis leur coût
on s'aperçoit que le gain par rapport à
l'économie et bien il est long à obtenir
en tout cas l'équilibre
une dernière chose l'ITE on en a parlé
tous l'isolation thermique par
l'extérieur est incompatible avec le
bâti patrimonial je parle même pas des
monuments historiques mais est
incompatible avec le petit patrimonial
et j'entends par là de tout le bâti des
SPR et des secteurs sauvegardés imagine
bien quand on commence alors que c'est
la solution effectivement on sait que
c'est la solution après probablement on
dit comme ça dans la peut-être la plus
performante en matière de bâtir ancien
c'est probablement pas la plus
performante du tout en tous les cas
aujourd'hui l'ITE n'est pas compatible
avec le bâti patrimonial voilà c'est
simple faut pas donc il faut trouver un
autre moyen d'intervenir pour lutter
contre ces gaz à effet de serre c'est le
principal objectif et c'est le chauffage
c'est sur la manière dont on chauffe un
bâtiment un monument historique on sait
qu'on chauffe très peu les bâtiments
donc là pour le coup ils sont pas très
dispendieux c'est sur la manière dont on
souffle les bâtiments dont on consomme
il faut plutôt réfléchir plutôt que de
parler d'isolation voilà j'ai quelques
propos j'essaie d'être bref et je sa
parole à mes confrères l'essentiel a été
dit et on souscrit nous en tant
qu'association des architectes du
patrimoine à tout ce qui a été dit au
dessus de cette table merci alors
Monsieur Raphaël gasttebois
vice-présidente de l'association vieille
maison française que pouvez-vous nous
dire après l'ensemble de ces auditions
et ses échanges passionnant d'ores et
déjà merci madame le Président alors
rassurez-vous je suis pas dépaysé de ce
côté-là parce qu'il se trouve que je
suis moi-même architecte et que j'ai été
architecte des Bâtiments de France dans
un certain nombre de départements
les vieilles maisons françaises les VMF
c'est une pas la plus ancienne
association du G7 patrimoine mais c'est
la plus grande association avec 18000
membres créés en 1958 déclaré d'utilité
publique en 1963 et bénéficiant aussi
des agréments ministériels
en tant que association
participant à l'élaboration et à
l'analyse des
de la législation et des programmes
comme celui dont on parle aujourd'hui
alors
dans cette association il n'y a pas que
des propriétaires effectivement les 10
millions de bâtiments anciens dont
parlait de logements anciens d'en parler
avec Christophe blanchardignac sont
habités et les VMF c'est une association
d'amateurs du patrimoine propriétaire ou
non de gens qui s'intéressent au bâti
anciens à la manière d'y habiter à la
manière de l'animé
et
l'habitabilité du bâti ancien c'est une
priorité pour les VMF également la
transmission du bâti ancien puisque moi
j'étais pas né au moment de la création
des VMF mais il y a un certain nombre de
gens qui sont nés dans cette association
parce que leurs parents y étaient et qui
ont pu avoir la transmission d'un
patrimoine familial qui ont pu aussi
devenir eux-mêmes propriétaires ou
pouvoir profiter
de ce que les propriétaires leur
offraient au cours de visite puisqu'il y
a énormément de visites qui sont
organisées par les VMF et donc on voit
bien que ce réseau alors on a des
délégués dans chaque département on a
des délégués régionaux également ce
réseau privé
anime transmet un patrimoine qui dans
tous les cas ne pourrait pas être
maintenu et transmis par la seule
puissance publique et donc c'est
extrêmement important de d'avoir
ce réseau associatif et cette action
cette ces initiatives privées en faveur
du patrimoine et aujourd'hui il est vrai
que les les membres des VMF comme
d'autres associations et les
propriétaires de bâtiments anciens se
sentent un petit peu isolés ils ont un
petit peu le sentiment que on a une
obsolescence programmée qui est mise en
place autour de ces diagnostics
énergétiques une sorte de complication
de quelque chose qui était pourtant si
simple à entretenir autrefois avec des
techniques effectivement locales des
matériaux locaux et un réseau d'artisans
qui qui était à proximité immédiate de
ce bâti et effectivement donc on a
aujourd'hui l'impression que tout cela
est vraiment contre-productif
alors évidemment
le la contre-productivité c'est pas le
maître mot du bâti ancien mais on voit
que le rythme
on parlait de l'action qui doit être
différente le rythme aussi est très
différent aujourd'hui plus aucun
propriétaire de bâtiments anciens et
personne qui aime le patrimoine et qui
comprend comment y habiter ne se dit que
le bâti ancien doit déroger à la règle
et doit déroger à l'action collective de
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
et d'amélioration thermique personne n'a
cette idée là et personne ne demande une
espèce de dérogation de droit divin qui
serait que on peut s'affranchir de tous
les efforts et on a d'autant moins cette
idée là qu'on a l'impression que ces
efforts là sont intrinsèques au bâti
ancien et que effectivement le parfois
je parlais du rythme le rythme du bâti
ancien n'est pas celui du de des
diagnostics dont on parle aujourd'hui
parce qu'il faut prendre le temps
prendre le temps ça veut dire que on
sait très bien que tous les travaux fait
à la va-vite et les travaux qui sont
faits avec des matériaux inadaptés
peuvent être totalement irréversibles
alors que ce bâti là a traversé les
siècles et que il est sans doute parfois
si on veut être efficace
urgent de ne pas se précipiter et ça
c'est une une chose très importante dans
le bâtiment ancien et c'est ce qu'on les
témoignages au cours des visites
organisées par les VMF les témoignages
des habitants du bâti ancien c'est
parfois de dire que l'entrée de la
maison est plus froide que le séjour et
que c'est tout à fait normal et que donc
il faut surtout pas se précipiter à
aller changer la porte d'entrée parce
que il y a aucune raison que que la cage
d'escalier soit chauffée de la même
manière que le reste de la maison et que
un bon rideau isolant devant une fenêtre
ancienne peut permettre de vivre
confortablement dans sa maison sans
avoir pour autant une urgence absolue à
changer toutes les fenêtres dont on sait
pertinemment que sur la plupart des
bâtiments anciens elle représente pas
plus de 15% du problème donc
effectivement il y a une
urgence à ne pas gaspiller
une et ça les architectes du patrimoine
et Monsieur Laporte l'a bien rappelé
la le fait de garder les matériaux
anciens c'est pas du fétichisme c'est
aussi
du développement durable de la
réutilisation parfois la réutilisation
de matériaux anciens qui peut être
nécessaire et aussi une vraie conscience
de l'environnement on parlait tout à
l'heure des problèmes de sable
savez-vous que pour fabriquer du verre
il faut des millions de tonnes de sable
et que aujourd'hui le double voire le
triple vitrage est une une aberration
totale du point de vue écologique parce
que effectivement on va se créer des
problèmes de non ventilation des locaux
mais on va en plus finalement avoir
engagé des dépenses considérables pour
l'environnement et donc voilà
effectivement sur le coup de
restauration ou d'entretien du bâti
ancien la restauration ça peut coûter
cher mais ça nécessite une approche
globale et c'est un projet qui peut être
soit de réutilisation de transformation
mais l'entretien c'est pas forcément
quelque chose de très coûteux pour
parvenir à l'entretien il faut avoir
parfois une bonne restauration au départ
ou alors il faut avoir eu un entretien
continu mais effectivement quand on doit
revenir en arrière quand on a eu des
opérations qui ont été mal faites ou des
matériaux qui ont été
utilisés à mauvais escient la remise en
état pour le coup coûte très cher
quand vous avez une fenêtre ancienne
vous pouvez la restaurer la conserver
quand vous avez une fenêtre en PVC qui a
créé des problèmes de mérule et qui a
créé des tas de problèmes dans le
bâtiment il est urgent de la remplacer
et s'il faut la remplacer par une
fenêtre à l'ancienne ou une fenêtre
réalisée à l'identique de ce qu'elle
était avant effectivement ça va coûter
assez cher
une fenêtre industrielle inadaptée
[Rires]
donc
nous au VMF on a la proposition qu'on
fait c'est d'aider les gens à habiter
dans l'ancien et aider à habiter dans
l'ancien ça veut dire qu'effectivement
il y a pas que les promoteurs il y a pas
que enfin les opérations de rénovation
de l'habitat c'est pas uniquement des
opérations type
malropatrimoine avec parfois des travaux
qui ont l'air bien mais qui sont pas
toujours
judicieux du point de vue y compris de
la politique du logement etc
essayons de ne pas empêcher les gens
d'habiter dans le bâti ancien à travers
des mesures contre-productives et là on
aura fait un pas considérable et donc
c'est pourquoi nous sommes tout à fait
partis prenantes de cette
ce texte que vous allez recevoir dans
les heures ou les jours qui viennent qui
est un compromis non pas un compromis
difficile mais au contraire un consensus
entre les associations qui travaillent
sur le patrimoine avec les architectes
et je pense que on nous a dit d'ailleurs
un
de vos collègues sénateurs nous disaient
que on était moins efficace que les
médecins et les pharmaciens pour faire
du lobbying mais on va essayer de se
soigner et on va essayer de d'être
meilleur parce que le leur est grave
voilà
merci merci beaucoup donc il nous reste
pour finir ce premier tour de table
ronde messieurs les architectes des
bâtiments de France
oui nous sommes madame la Présidente de
représentants de l'Association Nationale
d'architectes des bâtiments de France à
être de nouveau voir donc on va se
répartir la parole
pour vous livrer un témoignage sur ce
que la manière dont les architectes des
bâtiments de France peuvent aborder un
projet de rénovation thermique du bâti
ancien et également la manière dont
l'association nationale s'est saisie du
sujet en participant à divers ateliers
donc notamment avec les organismes
certificateurs et les
bureaux d'études thermiques qui sont
chargés des labellisations BBC etc donc
je vais certainement peut-être dire des
choses qui sont su de tous mais la
performance énergétique d'un bâtiment
global c'est une c'est un cocktail
énergétique extrêmement complexe qui
inclut évidemment la production de
chaleur qui inclut le confort thermique
d'été qui inclut l'enveloppe bien sûr
qui inclut aussi la manière dont elle a
été construite
les matériaux
qu'est-ce qu'il a fallu comme énergie
pour amener ces matériaux l'usage on en
a parlé bon voilà c'est quelque chose de
très varié très divers aujourd'hui le
DPE il a été conçu pour simplifier cette
situation extrêmement complexe afin de
pouvoir répondre à une certaine
catégorie construite qui est quand même
très majoritaire et pouvoir proposer des
réponses simples adaptées et directement
vérifiables donc quand on l'utilise dans
ce cadre là effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui peut être vertueux le problème
qu'on constate c'est qu'il est utilisé
aujourd'hui
alors que c'est un modèle qui s'applique
avec un champ qui est limité c'est qu'il
est il est utilisé en dehors de ce champ
tout simplement donc
il y a plusieurs sujets il y a déjà la
manière dont il est utilisé par les
diagnostiqueurs c'est à dire qu'il est
inclut une certaine complexité qui n'est
pas toujours comprise par les
diagnostiqueurs et qui n'est pas pour
utiliser par exemple les doubles
fenêtres sont tout à fait possible dans
le DPE mais c'est quelque chose qui
n'est jamais proposé il est également
utilisé avec des des techniques
scientifiques qui sont connues c'est à
dire que quand on ne connaît pas un
matériau on va partir sur la pire
situation on va partir sur voilà le pire
critère alors qu'en réalité si on peut
regarder en détail le matériau on
constate qu'il a quand même de bonnes
performances donc il est très lié aussi
finalement à la manière dont on analyse
les matériaux et c'est vrai que les
matériaux standardisés et industriels
ont un avantage dans cette compétition
entre les matériaux puisque ils font
l'objet de de vérification en chambre
etc et qu'on peut vraiment les
caractériser donc tout le sujet que nous
on a quand on arrive en rendez-vous avec
des personnes qui arrivent avec ce DPE
c'est de leur expliquer que
effectivement ça n'est pas un calcul
thermique scientifique qui ne peut pas
du tout être réinterroger et donc nous
ce qu'on essaye c'est justement cette
intelligence du projet pour essayer
d'aller plus loin alors ce qu'on
constate c'est que dans les trois disons
catégories de de programmation de
travaux qui sont faites dans les DPE
pour être par étape à un meilleur à une
meilleure performance souvent pour ce
qui concerne la pour ce qui concerne
l'isolation des combles ou les choses
simples on y arrive c'est quand on veut
arriver vraiment à des à des
performances très importantes avec un
très grand
disons programme de travaux qu'on va
finir par être quand même très invasif
donc là en fait on tombe aussi par
rapport à ma prime rénov et à tous les
accompagnements qui sont cités sur une
manière de programmer les travaux qui
est assez systématiquement une manière
de alors d'un côté effectivement il faut
voir la rénovation thermique de façon
globale mais d'un autre côté il faut
laisser le temps aux travaux de se faire
je pense notamment au bailleur sociaux
qui doivent
produire des projets de travaux sur deux
trois ans pour être financé alors qu'ils
ont des problèmes de dans son tiroir
alors qu'ils ont des problèmes de voilà
et donc quand on arrive en rendez-vous
il faut prendre en compte toutes ces
thématiques là pour essayer d'amener de
l'intelligence et de l'ingénierie et ça
ça prend du temps et donc effectivement
comme le disait
comment dire les autres les autres
interlocuteurs ce temps-là dans cette
situation d'urgence face au DPE on ne
l'a pas donc voilà moi je l'Association
nationale des des architectes des
bâtiments de France rejoint l'ensemble
des des intervenants pour dire que les
sons simplement ce temps là pour pouvoir
adapter les choses pour pouvoir
peut-être faire évoluer le DPE d'une
certaine manière d'une certaine manière
pour qu'il soit plus caractérisée sur le
bâti ancien pour pouvoir évidemment
former les diagnosticurs pour qu'ils
puissent utiliser toutes les composantes
du DPE qui est très riche mais qui est
mal utilisé et puis pour pouvoir aussi
nous nous structurer pour que nous
puissions faire comment dire construire
ses partenariats qui étaient évoqués par
Madame Gatel et Monsieur Armand pour
qu'on puisse être sur un territoire tout
un ensemble d'acteurs
construire
cette pensée que le DPE et doit être
parole d'évangile et doit être appliquée
tel quel voilà je laisse la parole merci
beaucoup à vous monsieur de beau regard
et puis bon beaucoup de choses ont été
dit quasiment tout je vous propose
d'essayer d'illustrer un peu ce qui a
été dit pour peut-être mettre en
résonance le premier sujet pourquoi le
DPE n'est pas adapté je me suis posé la
question et j'ai appelé à un éditeur de
logiciel la semaine dernière je pourrais
essayer de comprendre il se trouve qu'on
fait exactement le même constat
l'éditeur de l'un des trois éditeurs
nationaux de logiciels sont
d'accord sur le fait que le DPE le
calcul de l'inertie aujourd'hui n'est
pas adapté au bâti ancien pourra simple
la bonne raison que il s'appuie sur un
algorithme qui leur a été fourni et non
pas qu'ils ont calculé jusqu'à 2016 il
est calculé pas les maçonnerie de pierre
parce que c'était des choses trop
complexes à calculer par rapport à la
complexité et tout ça aujourd'hui quoi
en 2021 leur a été fourni à l'algorithme
qu'ils
et qu'ils ne savent pas aujourd'hui
justifier pour vous donner une
illustration très concrète pour arriver
aujourd'hui à un cloison tel que le
demande lare 2020 c'est-à-dire 30 ou 40
cm si on l'applique à la maçonnerie de
pierre il faudrait des murs entre 4 et 6
mètres d'épaisseur pour avoir la même
performance on voit bien qu'il y a un
problème de calcul regardez le logement
dans lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui à
des performances à des qualités il n'est
pas parfait mais il a des qualités
notamment par rapport à la chaleur au
confort au confort d'été et d'ailleurs
on parle bien de réchauffement
climatique donc le confort d'été et un
des grands enjeux de l'architecture de
demain d'aujourd'hui et de demain et
pour lequel
l'architecture patrimoniale dans la
plupart des cas est extrêmement
performante donc c'est un bâtiment qui a
des performances aujourd'hui qui ne sont
mal calculés par le logiciel donc il y a
un sujet de calibrage logiciel sur
lequel les éditeurs sont en phase avec
le discours qu'on porte aujourd'hui ce
qui est plutôt une bonne nouvelle c'est
à dire que pour le même discours et
qu'il faudrait essayer de travailler et
la personne que j'ai eu travail dans les
groupes de travail depuis les années 80
toute l'évolution qui est fait
exactement le même constat que ce que
celui qu'on fait aujourd'hui donc c'est
plutôt plutôt bon signe c'est à dire que
on réfléchit de la même manière
le deuxième sujet qui a été largement
évoqué c'est la présence de l'eau dans
les maçonneries anciennes c'est un sujet
qui est extrêmement important pour deux
raisons sur la pérennité des maçonneries
en fait quand vous mettez quand vous
piéger de l'eau dans une maçonnerie vous
dissolvez les mortiers mais aussi vous
dégradez les pierres temps de schiste de
pire quelqu'un etc et vous arrivez sur
un moyen terme c'est pas le long terme
un moyen terme sur une dégradation une
désorganisation qui va arriver à la
dégradation de l'ensemble du bâti ancien
cet ensemble se bâti ancien va être
dégradé si on part sur les ite ça a été
dit effectivement largement mais c'est
aussi sur les iti donc les illusions par
l'intérieur d'où la respiration qui est
extrêmement importante cette respiration
et ne passe elle ne peut passer que par
des enduits à la terre ou des enduits ou
à la chaux ce qui est très intéressant
parce que en travaillant sur ces
respirations on enlève
et finalement c'est pas forcément très
coûteux donc
sur sur les risques et les enjeux il y a
un enjeu effectivement de pérennité on
l'a dit de cadre de vie aussi mais il y
a aussi un enjeu sur les filières que
vous posiez madame la Présidente aussi
la question c'est filière existe-t-elle
encore et les ressources existent-elles
encore où elles existent on a la chance
en France d'avoir des très grandes
filières d'artisans il n'y a pas de
patrimoine sans artisan clairement c'est
pas nous architectes c'est pas nous
artisan sauf l'association sauf si il y
a parmi les associations des artisans
qui auront travaillé à la restauration
du patrimoine et cette artisanat qui est
souvent des petites entreprises est un
patrimoine immatériel très important en
France et sur lequel la massification de
la rénovation thermique peut
complètement écraser cette filière et la
faire disparaître de manière définitive
et on mettra du temps à renouveler cette
filière donc il s'agit ici aussi de la
sauvegarde de cette filière d'artisans
et de toute l'économie qui va autour y
compris les filières courtes puis dire
courtes on parle de la pierre ou pas on
peut parler du bois on peut parler des
sables on a parlé des sables tout ça qui
font le patrimoine sont aussi en jeu
dans cette rénovation thermique c'est
c'est effectivement très important
aussi de l'attractivité des territoires
aujourd'hui beaucoup de villages
beaucoup de territoires ruraux sont
attractifs pas seulement pour le
tourisme mais aussi pour l'habitation on
voit bien dans nos métiers au quotidien
des personnes qui viennent notamment
après le covid qui sont beaucoup
installés dans les villages parce que
c'était les villages dans lequel on
était bien on parle beaucoup de
patrimoine aujourd'hui mais le
patrimoine c'est aussi le cadre de vie
et c'est extrêmement important parce que
ça ne touche tout au quotidien ça nous
permet aussi de travailler sur un
environnement et sur le maintien d'une
population en milieu rurale ça c'est le
télétravail et les développements des
technologies nous aident aussi à
retrouver un nouveau paradigme une
nouvelle population dans les milieux
ruraux et qui permettent aussi d'avoir
une bonne répartition et éviter
l'étalement urbain dans les villes il y
a un enjeu aussi de des mouvements de
population et je vais m'arrêter là mais
pour les objectifs je rejoins bien
évidemment les objectifs qui ont été
très bien formulés par le directeur du
patrimoine en trois points qu'on a fait
sans se concerter la même analyse
le travail sur un DPE un DPE très
performant plus adapté en prenant en
compte un algorithme qui prennent en
compte les maçonnées anciennes oui
j'oubliais il y avait pas que des
mauvaises surprises dans ces échanges
avec cette idée éditeur de
DPE j'ai pu découvrir que en fait les
enduits correcteurs comme les enduits
chauffants sont pris assez bien en
compte dans le calcul du début alors ça
c'est plutôt une très bonne nouvelle
parce que on se pose la question par
exemple quand on a une maçonnerie de 30
ou 40 cm qui n'est pas du tout assez
pour l'inertie et ben un enduit à
chauffant et aujourd'hui pris en compte
dans le diagnostic et dans une
amélioration conséquente pour pour ça
donc il y a déjà des LG qui existent et
qui sont sur lequel il faut agir premier
donc un dépe plus adapté le deuxième sur
une prise en compte de l'équilibre
structurel de l'équipe hydrique des
bâtiments aujourd'hui quand on refait un
enduit à la chaux par exemple une
maçonnique un enduit aussi ment qu'on
purge et qu'on refait un enduit à chaud
pour le faire respirer mais aussi pour
le briser aujourd'hui ce n'est pas du
tout identifié comme étant une
rénovation thermique et pourtant on l'a
vu c'en est une et en plus ça travaille
à la valorisation il ne serait-ce que
d'avoir une TVA à 5,5 comme c'est le cas
pour la rénovation thermique et d'avoir
la possibilité de déduire de ses impôts
comme c'est le cas pour rénovation
thermique serait déjà une première aide
conséquente pour cette rénovation
thermique et cet équilibre hydrique qui
participera mon confrère monsieur
Laporte là c'est bien dit à prolonger le
cycle de vie autrement dit avoir un
retour carbone existant et à prolonger
un retour carbone déjà en place faire de
la réparation plutôt que de faire de la
rénovation ce qui est quand même la
première des sobriétés on parle de
sobriété énergétique là on est vraiment
là dessus
il faut garder en tête quelques chiffres
1 kg de matériaux mis en oeuvre sur un
chantier c'est 40 kg de matières
premières consommées 40 c'est énorme et
la réparation c'est aussi toute cette
sobriété qui est en place
et le dernier sujet on l'a dit je le dis
quand même
la formation des diagnostiqueurs et
peut-être travailler un socle commun et
on est tous disponible la preuve on est
là pour travailler à ce socle commun qui
pourrait être partagé sur les
diagnostics voilà ce que je pourrais
dire sur le sujet merci beaucoup les uns
et les autres c'était très intéressant
je vais devoir vous quitter parce que
j'ai un rendez-vous chez le président
Larcher donc bien évidemment c'est
monsieur le rapporteur maintenant qui va
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions mais je laisse la présidence
de la commission d'enquête à Sabine
dragster et ça ne pouvait pas mieux
tomber que ce soit elle qui achève cette
présidence de commission sur cette table
ronde sur le patrimoine en tout cas
merci beaucoup de vos interventions et
on va je l'espère en tout cas avec
monsieur le rapporteur en tenir compte
de façon à ce que nous fassions des
préconisations à issus de notre rapport
qui soit aussi en phase avec tout ce que
vous nous avez dit et toutes les
informations que vous nous avez
apportées merci en tout cas à tous pour
le travail la passion que vous mettez
dans le cadre de vos différentes
responsabilités pour préserver notre
patrimoine ancien au sens large notre
bâti patrimonial merci beaucoup Sabine
je te laisse la place et je laisse la
parole sans plus tarder à monsieur le
rapporteur merci
merci Madame madame la Présidente
et merci à vos différentes interventions
qui étaient à la fois riches
complémentaires et je pense que le
message est bien et on a bien reçu le
message en tout cas et c'est vrai que
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait
évidemment évidemment
identifié quand on a on a décidé en tout
cas de mettre en place cette commission
d'enquête sur la rénovation thermique
parce que
ça a été dit les enjeux sur la
rénovation thermique oui ces deux enjeux
écologiques mais comme toujours des
enjeux sociaux sanitaires et aussi de
patrimoine de qualité de vie de cadre de
vie donc c'est effectivement cet
ensemble là qui qui doit être pris en
compte quand on intervient quand on
travaille sur les bâtiments et quand on
améliore leur leur à la fois leur aspect
et cette rénovation thermique après j'ai
un peu l'impression que tout ce que vous
avez pu décrire c'est vrai que tout cet
aspect là est accéléré par ce dispositif
qui est mis en place et qui veut aller
vite mais récupérer enfin qui veut aller
vite à la fois ça fait quand même 20 ans
qu'on réfléchit à comment comment isoler
les bâtiments et comment travailler sur
la rénovation thermique mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que voilà on accélère avec
des avec des dispositifs mais c'est vrai
que tu n'asparté mais la question de la
dégradation du patrimoine
on va dire ancien
on l'a vu aussi au-delà de la question
de la rénovation thermique et on le voit
encore quoi donc il y a aussi une
question de une question de formation je
viens d'un territoire par exemple où je
vois beaucoup de façades et qui sont
l'enduit étant levée alors que elles
étaient absolument enfin pour pour
mettre les pierres
apparente alors qu'elles étaient pas du
tout fait pour ça et qu'elles étaient
destinées au contraire avec des enduits
et souvent des enduits colorés etc et
avec des choses parfois dramatiques en
fait je trouve en tout cas sur le
patrimoine qui peuvent se passer donc
enfin voilà je pense qu'il faut aussi
sur cette question en tout cas de la
formation de la formation c'est pour
savoir je suis aussi architecte la
formation des dans les écoles
d'architecture et sur comment on
appréhende en tout cas ce patrimoine qui
est qui est important
ensuite je trouve ce qui a été
intéressant qui a été dit c'est que
c'est vrai qu'en plus c'est plutôt une
chance et en tout cas on a beaucoup à
apprendre puisque c'est vrai que quand
on regarde ce type de bâtiment ça a été
dit c'était plutôt des architectures qui
se sont construites avec des matériaux
des matériaux locaux les matériaux qui
étaient disponibles sur le sur le
territoire que ça soit le bois la terre
etc la pierre et voilà et tous les
matériaux et donc on a beaucoup à
apprendre en tout cas et dans dans cette
mission cette commission d'enquête c'est
vrai qu'on a aussi travaillé sur comment
réutiliser justement des matériaux
sourcées comme entre mettre en place des
filières locales et donc je pense que là
on a des liens assez forts à réfléchir
et à trouver qui passe aussi par de la
formation on a pu au cours de cette de
cette commission également à visiter les
grands ateliers de L'Isle-d'Abeau et
puis également un lien avec l'école
architecture de Grenoble qui travaille
sur toute la question justement de la
terre et de la réutilisation justement
de de matériaux biosourcés qui
travaillent à la fois avec archite est
ingénieurs et artisans pour voir comment
mieux mettre en oeuvre en tout cas
l'ensemble de ces de ces matériaux et
également innover parce que c'est vrai
que derrière ça il y a aussi cette
innovation alors après sur ce que vous
avez pu dire par rapport au ce qui est
mis en place et sur comment on peut
améliorer en tout cas en tout cas les
conditions thermiques de ces de ces
bâtiments moi j'avais plusieurs
peut-être plusieurs questions c'est vrai
que tu es beaucoup sujet du DPE
j'ai entendu un peu moi je voulais
peut-être que vous précisiez sur est-ce
que vous pensez
si j'entends la dernière intervention
était plutôt de dire qu'on peut faire
évoluer ce DPE et que on peut le rendre
plus plus adapté en tout cas au bâtiment
au bâtiment ancien la prise en compte
justement de de ces différents types ces
différents types de matériaux et qu'on
peut mieux l'intégrer à la condition qui
est qui est de la formation aussi sur
les différents diagnostiqueurs ou est-ce
que peut-être que sur ces types de
bâtiments il faut peut-être
abandonner ce type de réflexion en tout
cas d'avoir cette cette orientation avec
un DPE et en se disant il faut il faut
augmenter les faire monter les marches
comme ça et peut-être avoir quelque
chose de plus je dirais peut-être plus
classique mais elle est plutôt vers un
audit énergétique beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus fort beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
précis pour vous parler de temps aussi
pour avoir aussi avec une maîtrise
d'oeuvre une vraie réflexion sur ce
qu'il faudrait faire pour améliorer les
conditions les conditions thermiques du
bâtiment mais du coup sortir en fait de
on va dire de ce qui est proposé je
pense qu'à les faire dans ce que j'ai
entendu il y a un petit peu les deux
donc je sais pas si vous pouviez
préciser en tout cas si vous pensez que
avec le DPE tel qu'il est fait on peut
le faire évoluer franchement j'ai pas
moi j'ai pas la réponse j'essaye de voir
un petit peu si on peut le faire évoluer
et que ça peut devenir un outil
intéressant et puis derrière qu'on peut
qu'on peut rentrer dans ce cadre là sur
ce type de bâtiment ou pas mais c'est
sûr que derrière il faudra aussi
accepter parce qu'on sait qu'avec les
critères actuels on aura des bâtiments
qui n'atteindront jamais les
performances qu'on peut souhaiter sur
d'autres sur d'autres bâtiments enfin
des performances au sens ce qui peut
rentrer en tout cas dans le cadre dans
le cadre du DPE ouais j'ai un petit
retour d'expérience sur
l'Alsace où j'ai vu effectivement il y a
un travail qui a été fait par le cerema
ladreal et la dracal
franchement c'est Bourgogne plutôt sur
une démarche habiter l'ancien en Alsace
et sur lequel ils ont travaillé sur le
DPE tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui mais
auquel ils ont adapté adapté pardon un
diagradar c'est à dire que en utilisant
la note ils ont mis comme choix de la
rénovation en critères le gain
énergétique bien sûr le patrimoine et
l'architecture
l'absence de risque lié à l'humidité
dans les dans les dans les structures
les inhumation de l'effet de parois
froid de confort d'été et en fait selon
il y a plusieurs manières d'atteindre un
bon niveau acceptable du DPE et ben la
voix a été choisie en prenant en compte
les meilleures notations cet ensemble de
diagramme ce qui a permis et c'est
exactement ce qui était décrit à
l'instant d'avoir des approches qui sont
plutôt patrimoniales et autrement dit
plus sobre et en même temps en prenant
les structures les équilibres donc il y
a des choses qui existent et qui sont
aujourd'hui compatibles avec le DPE même
si le DPE aujourd'hui est quand même mal
calculé c'est à dire qu'avec un calcul
et on a de la donnée scientifique
monsieur aglave parler du du de l'étude
battant c'est une étude qui date de 2011
qui est pas si vieille que ça et qui est
quand même avec beaucoup beaucoup de
données scientifiques qui a été fait par
le ministère de la transition écologique
et qui nous permettra sur notamment sur
les structures anciennes vraiment de
d'accumuler de la donnée secondement il
y a actuellement cours et piloté par le
céréma le projet sereine qui est un
projet d'instrumentalisation de 250
bâtiments pour le Grand Ouest mais
j'imagine que pour les grands secteurs
c'est la même chose donc on est en train
de créer de la donnée aujourd'hui en
temps réel en instrumentant les éléments
sur le bâtiment ancien donc
effectivement ça va être un peu lent
peut-être mais on a déjà une partie de
données scientifiques et on est en train
d'accumuler donc sur les dispositions
aujourd'hui sous réserve comprenne en
compte la pérennité des structures mais
aussi la valorisation du patrimoine
architecture architectural du
patrimonial il y a des choses qui se
réalisables avec un accompagnement et
surtout peut-être une approche
multicritère qui n'existe pas
que le propriétaire que l'habitant peut
faire de son de son bâtiment et c'est
vrai que dans la catégorie des bâtiments
patrimoniaux bâtiment ancien qui sont
souvent de grandes surfaces le fait de
calculer tout par rapport
au mètre carré habitable c'est un peu
une stupidité on n'habite pas on va dire
dans une grande maison et le sont toutes
dans le monde rural souvent même si ce
ne sont pas des châteaux on n'habite pas
de la même façon c'est pas la même
intelligence et on n'a pas partout la
même température il y a des zones
tampons il y a des dépendances qui sont
bien situées bien exposés etc qui sont
pas du tout intégrés dans l'intelligence
aujourd'hui mise en jeu pour évaluer la
performance de ces bâtiments mais ils en
ont ils ont une intelligence toute
simple je disais tout à l'heure qui
n'ont pas encore été intégrés dans la
technique dans l'intelligence qui est la
nôtre aujourd'hui avec nos appareils et
nos et nos instruments très sophistiqués
les anciens étaient beaucoup plus
pragmatiques et je pense que il faut
revenir à ce à ce bon sens et vivre dans
une maison ancienne moi j'y vis toute
l'année et je peux vous dire que c'est
un véritable bonheur donc quand on nous
dit vous habitez des passoires
thermiques moi ça me vraiment ça me ça
me touche pas plus que ça ça m'agace
simplement je dis bah venez y vivre vous
allez comprendre peut-être et faire
évoluer votre donc le fait d'avoir
évacué on va dire l'usage de ne plus
tenir compte de la façon dont les
responsables que nous sommes des
économies d'énergie que nous avons envie
de faire tous c'est une c'est une grave
erreur dans un dans un performance on
sait très bien il y a des études qui ont
tendance à le prouver que plus les
bâtiments vont être performants plus les
bâtiments vont être automatisés on parle
de la domotique aujourd'hui
l'intelligence artificielle se substitue
à l'intelligence humaine de plus en plus
et on va des responsabiliser petit à
petit l'usager qui se dit finalement ma
maison elle est passive bah moi je
continuer à être actif je peux continuer
à dépenser etc on peut arriver à ce type
de paradoxe vous voyez ce que je veux
dire il faut plutôt travailler sur
l'intelligence humaine plutôt que de
faire confiance à des mécanismes puisque
on est dedans aujourd'hui souvent
avec les volets roulants tout un tas de
choses tout un tas de choses qui qui ont
changé le mode que l'on avait autrefois
de vivre sa maison de l'habiter et de
vivre avec voilà donc je pense que ça
c'est important à dire dans les dans les
approches qu'on pourrait avoir et moi je
pense que le diagnostic tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout adapté au
bâti ancien alors effectivement on peut
se contenter d'un moyen terme en disant
qu'on est dans l'urgence qu'on pourra
pas arriver à la perfection que ça va
coûter très cher qu'il faut beaucoup de
temps times money donc on va pas le
faire ce choix mais il faudrait le faire
tout le monde le dit les scientifiques
le disent quand on fait des formations
c'est ce qu'on apprend c'est ce qu'on
fait passer comme message le bâti ancien
il est dans une dynamique et les moteurs
de calcul aujourd'hui ne sont pas dans
cette dynamique ils sont statique
alors les logiciels dynamiques qu'ils
existent il y a des Allemands qui les
ont mis au point il y en a quelques-uns
ils sont très peu utilisés parce qu'ils
demandent beaucoup de temps pour rentrer
les données et le diagnostiqueur
aujourd'hui pour 80 euros ou 90 euros
qu'ils demandent pour être payé ça peut
pas le faire comme on dit il a pas
suffisamment on va dire de dédommagement
pour passer le temps qu'il faudrait pour
pouvoir avoir véritablement une mesure
qui soit crédible par rapport justement
à cet écosystème dans les moteurs de
recherche n'ont pas compris ou ne se
sont ne se sont pas mis en accord avec
ce côté on va dire dynamique qui doit
être mesuré au pas horaires comme on le
dit sur le temps sur l'année donc c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que les
référentiels qui aujourd'hui sont
rentrés dans nos dans nos moteurs de
recherche dans nos moteurs de calcul des
DPO tels qu'ils ont été conçues pour le
bâtiment moderne et mais là le problème
c'est que le bâti ancien ben il souffre
par rapport à ça donc je pense que voilà
après c'est un choix on peut faire on
peut améliorer on peut faire faire
entrer les choses dedans plutôt qu'il y
ait des qu'il y a des comment dirais-je
des valeurs par défaut parce que le
diagnostiqueur dans son référentiel il
n'a pas par exemple la mention de d'un
enduit comment dirais-je qui va atténuer
les fêtes par voie froide effectivement
si on le fait rentrer dans le logiciel
on va améliorer le résultat je pense que
c'est des petites retouches de ce type
voilà ça existe déjà à condition que les
diagnostiquers soient formés à ça c'est
ça le problème c'est que le
diagnostiqueur il est pas forcément
formé à ça moi je peux je peux vous dire
j'ai vu des diagnostiqueurs chercher de
l'amiante dans des plafonds en terre à
la bourre animale vous savez autrefois
on faisait on faisait des plafonds à
labour animal c'est extraordinaire comme
technologie et il y a des poils de bête
ça le pourrit jamais donc quand on fait
les prélèvements dans le bâti ancien
qu'on n'est pas on va dire instruit des
matériaux des logiques et des
savoir-faire on est suspect quand on a
un petit poil comme ça qu'on sort on le
met dans les prouvettes on l'envoie la
au laboratoire enfin c'est une
aberration quoi mais qui montre à quel
point c'est pas une caricature moi je
l'ai vécu
l'ignorance est grande par rapport aux
bâti anciens des gens qui normalement
sont professionnels du sujet
s'il vous plaît
voilà c'est à vous
merci beaucoup juste deux trois deux
trois réflexions pour conforter ce qui a
été dit ce qui va être dit aussi c'est
que effectivement le système de dépe
actuel est un système statique c'est une
image aujourd'hui
il n'est capable d'aucune projection
aucune dynamique et par conséquent il
est très défaillant en termes de
prévision d'inconfort d'été et on a une
vision aujourd'hui
d'économie d'énergie et de protection
par du froid mais en fait on a aussi un
volet
canicule à prendre en compte et si on
fait pas attention avec des matériaux
automatisés on va aggraver la situation
ça c'est la première réflexion de cette
nécessité de d'avoir en fait une vision
dynamique que ne permet pas le 3 c'est
le logiciel actuellement utilisé
la seconde réflexion c'est aussi par
rapport à votre intervention monsieur le
directeur qui est tout à fait
intéressant
si vous voulez
si on aurait si on se contente de parler
et c'est pas du je sais pas juste c'est
pas suffisant puisque on est tous
d'accord pour aller en fait 1948 mais il
y a donc dans les sites embarquables il
y a des documents de gestion soit des
plantes sauvegarde soit dépend de
valorisation de la crise du patrimoine
et aucun de ces documents n'a d'études
spécifiques sur le bâti sur lequel
intervient c'est-à-dire que on aurait
besoin dans chaque territoire d'avoir
une connaissance des besoins des
comportements de ce bâti patrimonial de
façon à ce que on puisse d'une part d'un
point de vue réglement et ça rejoint la
question de la France tout à l'heure
mais également d'un point de vue
d'incitation financière des
collectivités d'un point de vue des
citations financière de Lana puisque les
délégations locales qui attribuent les
subventions sont souvent méconnaissance
très forte de cette approche
particulière et le fait que l'on est une
vision je dirais mono-orienté énergie
qui est une nécessité à nouveau tout à
fait d'accord là-dessus mais quel est
mon orienté peut avoir des effets
pervers on a des retours de collectivité
du sud de la France qui nous disent que
la terre ne peut pas subventionner des
opérations de restauration
d'immeubles et donc de production de
logements y compris de logement avec un
caractère loyer modéré parce que le
point de départ de ces bâtiments anciens
étant donné que le gain de 35% qui exige
la nappe n'est pas atténuable et on peut
pas donc restaurer ces bâtiments-là et
donc il n'y a pas de subvention il y a
pas de restauration le patrimoine va se
dégrader on ne produit pas le logement
dans ces coeur de vie et on ne va pas
avoir un thermique quelqu'un que puis
toute façon voilà donc
ce qu'on dit tout ça c'est que il nous
faut une approche environnementale
qui comprend la culture qu'on prend le
social il comprend l'économie qui
comprend l'énergie et que tant qu'on
n'aura pas cette approche globale
effectivement on arrivera pas bien loin
il me semble aussi que alors nous on est
pour un DPE ancien jusqu'à présent
informé on est plutôt favorable à
travailler du pistolet mais je veux dire
que
en subventionne sans réfléchir
c'est quand même terrible quoi je veux
dire que tout à l'heure on a pris une
rénove avec des gestes on sait tous il
suffit de financer une pompe à chaleur
pour avoir un bon DPE on n'a rien fait
de plus on a besoin d'avoir et on n'a
pas non plus de moyens financiers de
d'incitation avec des travaux qui
seraient programmés dans le temps
aura le geste on va subventionner la
fenêtre l'isolation des combles mais on
n'a pas de vision globale qui
permettrait sur un des propriétés à deux
trois quatre six dix ans d'un intervenir
et de construire un projet avec des
soutiens financiers associés pendant
cette durée là c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel on peut pas dire du jour au
lendemain alors les tentatives de de la
rénovation globale qui ont été faits ne
permettent montre bien que on n'arrive
pas à avoir une efficacité importante
puisque en fait on n'a pas on n'a pas de
on arrive à des coûts de travaux
tellement élevés qu'on n'a pas la
rentabilité que l'on espérait et donc on
travaille pas comme correctement donc on
aurait besoin aussi d'avoir cette
logique de financement progressif
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur
Truchon le soir
merci madame la Présidente juste pour
prolonger la question de départ si vous
motorisez je vais aller un petit peu
plus loin
je laisserai aux hommes de là et aux
femmes de l'art pardon le soin d'établir
les nouveaux outils les nouveaux modes
de calcul ça n'est pas mon propos par
contre ce que je sais c'est qu'il est
vital essentiel que ces nouveaux outils
soient réajustés parce que sur le
terrain aujourd'hui on voit les
conséquences les conséquences elles sont
effectivement des dégâts considérables
par rapport au l'architecture par
rapport à nos paysages etc c'est une
chose j'entendais parler d'activité le
tourisme n'est pas que au-delà de tout
ça moi ce qui m'inquiète très fortement
c'est que parfois derrière la vertu il y
a une part de vis et je vois notamment
que lorsque l'on parlait à plusieurs
reprises des passoires je vois
aujourd'hui dans une société aujourd'hui
où l'on manque cruellement de logement
une offre de logement qui est en train
de se tarir
il n'y a plus de production de logements
neuf dans un certain nombre de domaines
notamment chez les bailleurs sociaux ça
c'est un vrai problème en France
aujourd'hui il y a un parcours
résidentiel qui est complètement rompu
il n'y a pas d'offre locative
aujourd'hui en tout cas dans beaucoup de
territoires enfin je veux pas
généraliser le cas à d'autres mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut plus faire ce
parcours résidentiel et concrètement
vous voyez ces histoires de DPE de
diagnostic de passoire font
qu'aujourd'hui on a une offre locative
qui est en train de disparaître et c'est
terrible et c'est pour ça que je parle
le vice derrière la vertu moi je vois
aujourd'hui sur le terrain des gens qui
me disent bah écoutez Monsieur le Maire
je ne vais pas je ne vais pas continuer
à louer mais appartements parce que les
diagnostics qui ont été donnés sont
catastrophiques et j'ai pas de solution
pour atteindre les objectifs dans une
société dans un dans un territoire où je
ne suis pas considéré en zone tendue
mais nous sommes en situation très
tendue je vais devant nous allons pardon
nous nous associons tous devant des
véritables catastrophes et c'est en ce
sens qu'il va être urgent effectivement
et donnez-nous c'est un petit peu l'idée
moi je souscris à tout ce que j'ai pu
entendre par les uns et par les autres
je pense pas aujourd'hui que la question
soit un problème d'argent souvent on dit
que les élus se plaignent parce qu'il y
a pas assez d'argent donc il y en a
encore faut-il bien l'utiliser peut-être
qu'il faudrait de réorienter aidez-nous
alors moi je suis en charge sur le
territoire je suis pas le seul mais nous
nous sommes quelques-uns en train
d'élaborer aujourd'hui un paysage avec
le contexte zan et bien aliexpliquer à
mes camarades élus que effectivement ils
ne pourront plus continuer le modèle du
pavillonnaire et c'est tant mieux mais
que par contre on va rester sur la
reconquête la reconstruction de la vie
sur la ville mais qui a pas d'outil à
mettre en face ou au contraire on va
rajouter encore de la contrainte à la
contrainte et bien là nous allons droit
dans le mur et c'est pour ça qu'il est
vraiment c'est un petit peu le cri du
coeur j'ai peut-être pas mis les formes
mais c'est un vrai enjeu pour moi
au-delà de la qualité architecturale du
développement du tourisme du bien-être
en ville c'est aussi la question du
logement aujourd'hui qui était essentiel
absolument monsieur Blanchard Dignac oui
madame la Présidente moi j'ai envie de
répondre à la question fort pertinente
du rapporteur oui sur le principe on
devrait pouvoir faire évoluer les choses
etc mais le sujet il en est plus là il
faut arrêter la machine infernale c'est
ça le sujet aujourd'hui on est en train
de on va on va vers dans un mur dans un
mur qui va consister à faire
progressivement parce qu'il y a des
générations de bâti anciens qui vont
progressivement arriver à cette cette
horrible qualification de passoire
thermique qui rendant le les choses un
louables invendable ou sinon avec une
des cotes etc donc il faut sur le papier
on devrait pouvoir faire ce qui a été
dit c'est-à-dire faire évoluer à
condition qu'on ait des personnes
formées pour mettre en oeuvre mais là on
a besoin d'un coup d'arrêt parce qu'on
n'est pas parti du bon pied on on est
parti avec une mauvaise vision
c'est-à-dire des parties avec une vision
globale on est parti de l'outil et puis
il faut pas se leurrer il y a le
patrimoine d'un côté les artisans et
puis il y a des secteurs industriels de
l'autre et donc c'est pas le même
rapport de force il y a toute une
économie du prêt à isolé du
de la rénovation forcée qui est en place
qui qui s'appuie sur des subventions
publiques abondantes qui fait de la
publicité ou pas je ne sais pas en tout
cas qui qui va démarcher des des
propriétaires un peu désemparés qui
savent pas comment s'en sortir donc sur
le papier on devrait pouvoir arriver à
faire cette évolution par l'intérieur
mais je crois que le moment est venu
d'intervenir politiquement en marquant
un coup d'arrêt c'est la seule manière
de faire bouger les choses sérieusement
sinon on va vers une un désastre
programmé
tout à fait c'est vraiment le sens aussi
de cette commission d'enquête Françoise
si madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur je pense qu'on a eu cet
après-midi un discours très vrai et qui
n'a aucune hostilité
à l'égard de l'amélioration de
performance énergétique ou en tout cas
de l'Écologie du Développement durable
je pense que vous voulez bien entendu et
bien et bien compris et qu'en même temps
je pense que nous avons comme nous
aimons faire en France parce que sans
doute sommes-nous extrêmement cartésien
nous avons mis en équation ou sous forme
de norme ce qui est une exigence
c'est-à-dire on a défini que la passoire
thermique
se définissait à partir d'un résultat
inférieur à une performance ce modèle là
qui est sans doute très vrai que je ne
conteste pas il ne peut pas s'adapter à
ce qui est un organisme vivant et
certains l'ont très bien dit c'est à
dire la performance énergétique d'un
bâti ancien l'été est assez remarquable
par rapport à un bâti moderne moi qui
veut aussi dans une maison ancienne je
sais qu'il y a des pièces où je ne vais
pas l'hiver et certaines où je vais
l'été parce que voilà il y a
certainement quelque chose autour de
l'exigence de la manière dont on va
vivre qui est important moi j'entends
avec plaisir la réflexion du rapporteur
sur la nécessité de reconsidérer le DPE
mais sincèrement je pense que on ne
pourra pas transformer un modèle
assis sur la norme un modèle entre
guillemets vraiment performant qui
permettent d'atteindre l'objectif que
vous voulez et que nous partageons tout
à fait donc moi je ne crois pas
à notre capacité à convaincre une
adaptation du début parce qu'on a plus
le temps c'était dit donc moi je serais
assez favorable à une proposition
peut-être dis positif monsieur le
rapporteur pardonnez-moi mais elle n'a
aucune malhonnêteté dans l'esprit c'est
un moratoire
sur le bâti alors peut-être prenons-nous
effectivement en 1948 je ne sais pas ce
qui permet en tout cas de réfléchir
parce que cela a été dit je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons aussi des
opérateurs de DPE je suis navré ça n'est
pas une critique mais qui ne connaissent
pas la particularité d'un bâti ancien
qui a son intelligence de performance y
compris thermique donc moi je suis
plutôt favorable un moratoire parce que
je souscris à ce qu'elle dit Y4 ans qui
est maire d'une ville épiscopale
treillée ce n'est pas rien qui
aujourd'hui combien d'habitants à
Tréguer combien de divisions et des
Staline au pape dit nous
2500 habitants qui est aujourd'hui une
centralité qui se bat et qui s'engage
avec son agglo pour faire revenir des
gens dans le centre-ville or si nous
n'arrivons pas à permettre que un bâti
ancien puis s'accueilli
des habitants que les gens ont envie de
revenir ça veut dire que c'est un
commerce de centre-ville qui disparaît
c'est la vitalité des communes on ne
saura pas logé les gens alors
qu'aujourd'hui on a des millions de gens
à relogés donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on
soit sans doute très intelligent mais au
vrai sens du terme et qu'on considère
que la performance énergétique qu'on
attend d'un bâtiment des années 80 elle
se justifie sans aucun doute mais que
dans un bâti ancien d'abord vous ne
vivrez pas de la même manière et vous ne
serez jamais en T-shirt le 24 décembre
voilà mais que il en va vraiment moi je
crois de la qualité du bâti de
l'aménagement du territoire et de la
capacité de loger les dans des
centres-villes donc si on pouvait
résonner un peu en écosystème ce serait
pas mal et se donner le temps d'un
moratoire pour permettre de construire
des outils mais tous ensemble vous vous
l'avez dit puisque aussi une
intelligence de l'homme de l'oeuvre
c'est à dire quand on comprend que voilà
mettre du PVC
avec un bâti ancien un moment ça se
détruit donc voilà ma proposition
monsieur le rapporteur qui n'est pas
révolutionnaire qui n'est pas rebelle
mais parce que je partage des objectifs
qui se veut et après cette horreur que
je viens de commettre je devrais quitter
à 18h merci Monsieur
toi aussi parce que tu es en train
exprime que mon toget
je voulais saluer Martin Malvy avec qui
je travaillais en tant que mère mais je
crois qu'il est il est parti et cimentin
je le salue je le remercie par rapport à
la question du rapporteur et aux
propositions que vous avez faites et
notamment celle concernant le moratoire
j'entends je pense qu'effectivement ça
serait une solution
d'attente à adapter mais peut-être
faudrait-il le le comment dire le
justifier l'argumenté pour pour le faire
comprendre par tout le monde
il a été évoqué l'un d'entre vous a
évoqué la notion de temps de retour
carbone qui renvoie
à une méthode d'évaluation qui
s'appelait l'analyse ainsi que de vie
qui est applicable au bâtiment il y a
des normes pour ça etc je m'interroge je
suis pas du tout spécialiste du sujet je
m'interroge sur la possibilité et
peut-être est-ce déjà étudié mise en
oeuvre par certains cabinets spécialisés
de procéder à des analyses ainsi que de
vie pour le bâti ancien ou au
patrimonial donc sur la base d'une
rétrospective du fonctionnement en fait
du du bâtiment du matériau voilà jusqu'à
la situation actuelle comparer à des
analyses ainsi que de vie pour pour les
pour les bâtiments contemporains ce
qu'on construit aujourd'hui voilà donc
ça serait une façon de d'introduire des
comparaisons de durabilité en fait entre
le patrimoine ancien et et patrimonial
et le et le patrimoine contemporain et à
venir je sais pas si ça existe si les
cabinets se sont lancés là-dedans mais
ça pourrait peut-être être une piste
intéressante pour valoriser tous les
aspects et notamment cet aspect
fondamental qui est celui de la
durabilité du bâti ancien et
patrimonialement voilà et je termine
vous redonnera la parole parce que je
vois qu'il y a une demande d'expression
par rapport à ça je m'interroge aussi et
ça m'intéresserait d'avoir votre votre
avis là-dessus
la prise en compte de la notion de
valeur patrimoniale
eu égard à la question des émissions
carbone
voilà si comme vous l'appelez notamment
à travers du le moratoire bon il est
fait le constat qu'effectivement il y a
des rejets de carbone plus importants
sur ce type de bâti que sur ce qu'on
construit aujourd'hui avec l'énorme
exigeante d'aujourd'hui ne serait-il pas
on donne du bien commun
patrimonial historique architectural de
finalement faire comme font les
entreprises qui aujourd'hui relâchent du
carbone dans le cadre de marché
compenser ces rejets carbone au titre et
au nom de l'intérêt général du bien
commun du bien commun national que
représente ce patrimoine donc ancien et
patrimonial historique on le qualifie
comme on veut voilà pourquoi je fais ces
propositions qui sont peut-être qui
peuvent peut-être apparaître comme
farfelu parce que je pense qu'il est il
est il est aussi nécessaire auprès de
l'ensemble des Français ou du plus grand
nombre de Français possible de mettre en
évidence mais ce bien commun historique
que l'on a en partage en réalité même si
on en est pas propriétaire ou
utilisateurs mais qu'on a en partage au
sein de la République voilà je pense que
cette idée là elle est peut-être à
travailler et qu'elle servira peut-être
tout le monde et particuliers la cause
que vous défendez et que je partage avec
vous
mais cela case
pour revenir sur la question de monsieur
le rapporteur c'est vrai que le DPE sur
facture dont on sait beaucoup moqué
finalement était assez intelligent et
subtil puisqu'il tenait compte justement
de l'usage
et peut-être enfin moi je suis tout à
fait favorable à cette idée de moratoire
on pourrait en attendant justement
d'avoir modélisé de façon plus
approfondie le fonctionnement du bâti
ancien rétablir cette méthode surfacture
de manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas rien
et nos échanges montrent que c'est
finalement peut-être une des meilleures
façons d'appréhender le voilà le
fonctionnement du bâti ancien parce
qu'on occupe pas toutes les pièces parce
que alors évidemment ça conduit alors il
y a quelques DPE qui sont vierges
parce que parce qu'il y a pas de facture
mais bon c'est pas grave c'est peut-être
la meilleure façon finalement de
d'appréhender les choses et ne soyons
pas encore une fois dans dans cette idée
de système c'est à dire que il faut
coller pouvoir coller une étiquette à
chaque logement là il y avait quelques
dépôts vierges bon ben c'est peut-être
pas si grave que ça
très bien monsieur Gastes bois
effectivement pour
l'amélioration du DPE tel qu'il est
quelque chose qu'on
pourrait souhaiter mais aujourd'hui le
problème c'est que le bâti ancien est
frappé d'un dignité face à dire que on
parle de logement indigne on a un
vocabulaire extrêmement dur sur le bâti
ancien et finalement il y a une pour
nous une forme d'escroquerie
intellectuelle dans ce qui a été mis en
place on a l'impression d'avoir de cette
fée rouler et on a besoin de retrouver
une véritable confiance avec une forme
de rupture finalement donc le moratoire
est une ce qu'on est on est des gens
bien élevés et malgré tout modéré donc
on parle de moratoire mais effectivement
c'est ça nous semble inconcevable
impensable de pouvoir discuter avec des
gens qui ont mis des habits verts mais
qui sont exactement les mêmes que ceux
qui voulaient tout raser dans les années
30 au nom de l'hygiénisme que ceux qui
faisaient des plans de résorption de
l'habitat insalubre à l'époque du fameux
carré et on a envie de retrouver
l'élan de la création des secteurs
sauvegardés les PSMV ont été une action
forte une vraie rupture pour mettre en
place une analyse fine et globale
bâtiment par bâtiment un diagnostic
précis et des réponses adaptées aux
besoins de logement et aux besoins de
l'urbanisme
alors que ceux qui avaient mis la
précédente politique en place disait que
si vous aviez 10% de logements insalubre
dans un quartier il fallait le raser
intégralement et donc effectivement on
se retrouve un petit peu devant ce même
cas de figure et devant la nécessité de
trouver une mesure culturelle
patrimoniale forte qui soit une réponse
à une une réponse inadaptée donc je
pense qu'effectivement
l'amélioration elle peut être faite mais
en
repartant pratiquement d'une page
blanche pour ce qui est du bâti d'avant
très bien merci Monsieur Laporte
oui je souscrire ce qui vient d'être dit
je crois que le microprocesseur le
disque dur de départ de la de la
fondation de du DPE n'était pas conçu en
considération du bâti ancien donc je
crois que moi je pense que se poser la
question de savoir comment on peut
l'améliorer me semble effectivement
un peu veine je pense qu'il vaut mieux
repartir et d'une page blanche comme
vous le dites et il est urgent j'allais
dire de prendre le temps de se mettre
effectivement autour d'une table on
vient de le faire aujourd'hui mais je
pense qu'il est pas difficile et
j'allais dire je pense qu'on doit
pouvoir à mon avis trouver des outils
appropriés vous en avez vous venez en
citer en revenant peut-être à cette
histoire de de consommation de de la
présentation facture qui peut être déjà
un outil un peu plus un peu plus fin par
rapport au bâti anciens mais moi
j'allais dire je me demande il faut même
l'appeler des PE parce que finalement le
DPE le diagnostic de performance
énergétique sur le bâti ancien il y a
quelque chose d'un peu comme ça une
espèce de pied de nez moi je me demande
s'il ne faut pas nous on réfléchit
depuis quelques années à l’amélioration
énergétique comme on le fait dans tous
les bâtis mais on le fait voilà avec en
posant un vrai diagnostic comme on pose
un diagnostic patrimonial sur un
monument sur du bâti patrimonial je
pense qu'il faut aussi poser un
diagnostic d'usage et un diagnostic
énergétique et j'allais dire que
peut-être qu'il faut lui donner un autre
nom le DPE s'accorderait pourrait ça
pourrait exister pour le bâti d'après
1948 mais je pense que pour le bâti
d'avant 1948 il faut peut-être inventer
un nouvel acronyme en tout cas trouver
un outil qui résumerait ce qui vient
d'être dit autour de table et qui serait
presque incontestable et légitime il
faut qu'il devienne totalement légitimes
et utilisable par les usagers les
locataires les propriétaires pour cet
outil soit perçu comme vraiment vertueux
par rapport à la au fondamentaux qui
sont posés on le voit bien d'ailleurs
tout ça vous l'avez souligné monsieur
Blanchard il y a des lobbies très forts
aujourd'hui et
qui rendent un peu voilà qu'il faut
c'est un peu complètement la donne et
je crois qu'il faut justement que le
patrimoine en France qui est quand même
un des un des aspects qu'il est plus je
dirais apprécié au monde dans notre pays
il faut pas qu'on tombe justement
dans ce piège là et qu'on stigmatise le
bâti ancien nous on est toujours outré
de voir de la manière dont on stigmatise
autour du sepathie je ne fais que redire
les propos qui sont échanges autour de
cette table donc je souscris aussi à
l'idée que il faut dès demain que il y a
effectivement un moratoire pour que l'on
cesse l'application de ce dps sur le
bâti d'avant 1948 les arguments ils
seront facile à trouver vous parliez de
durabilité effectivement et de temps de
retour carbone la durévalidité d'un bâti
ancien elle est même plus à démontrer il
est là depuis des siècles je dirais
aujourd'hui le bâti ancien
on n'a pas de garantie décennale dans le
bâtiment
il a le mérite déjà d'être là depuis des
siècles et je dirais que le bâti d'après
moderne aujourd'hui c'est ça durabilité
c'est la garantie des scénars donc la
question se pose même pas la
démonstration sera très très facile à
faire voilà merci merci Monsieur Laporte
à Monsieur Beauregard
je trouve que ce que disait monsieur
Lacaze sur retourner à la l'évaluation
sur facture c'est assez intéressant
parce que c'est exactement ce que disait
l'éditeur de logiciel pour en disant si
aujourd'hui on veut retrouver une mesure
la plus juste possible il faudrait
retourner sur la mesure sur facture dans
le bâtiment ancien c'est très
intéressant parce que effectivement ça
revient vraiment et en plus c'est
incisatif pour faire des économies pas
seulement sur les systèmes mais aussi
sur les éco-gestes et on sait très bien
que les éco-gestes soient extrêmement
important dans le bâtir ancien comme le
disait madame la Présidente Gatel tout à
l'heure et ben sur l'emplacement la
manière dont on vit d'une pièce à
l'autre dans le bâtir ancien c'est
fondamental pour faire écho aussi à ce
que ce qui était dit par Monsieur
cruchon en visio il y a des outils de
gestion thermique qui existent dans le
patrimoine on est en train d'en mettre
en place à Angers alors je suis la BF
danger donc je suis bien concerné on a
travaillé là dessus et on a mis en place
une étude thermique à l'échelle de du
centre-ville dans lequel on a fait 10
études de cas thermique avec un tamicien
marché du patrimoine qui aboutissent
préconisations donc c'est des modèles
type et qui arrivent à une déclinaison
dans le document d'urbanisme donc il y a
des choses qui existent c'est une étude
qui a coûté 45000 euros donc c'est pas
non plus incroyable qui est fait à
l'échelle des 200 hectares du
centre-ville d'Angers donc et financé à
50% par l'État donc c'est il y a des
choses qui existent des outils de
gestion qui sont fait et qui
correspondent aussi à ce qu'on a été dit
terme
architecte du patrimoine il faut
travailler pour faire des préconisations
d'amélioration qui s'appuie sur trois
fondements une action sur l'architecture
une action sur les systèmes et une
action sur les éco-gestes et c'est sur
ces trois préconisations avec un
principe de chiffrage et de gaz à
l'émission de à effet de serre il y a
des donc il y a déjà des initiatives on
parlait de l'Alsace tout à l'heure à
Angers on a avancé sur le sujet aussi
mais on est on est loin d'être les seuls
dans le dans le territoire il y a des
choses qui existent et qui ont
aujourd'hui une portée
réglementaire et cette étude on l'a pas
fait tout seul on a fait bien sûr
valider par les services de des
différents ministères associations Anna
et compagnie
merci Monsieur Beauregard alors je
voudrais vous poser une question
concernant le label de la Fondation du
Patrimoine que vous connaissez qui est
décerné aux propriétaires du bâtiment
patrimoniaux non protégé dans les
communes rurales et les communes de
moins de 20000 habitants et qui ouvre
droit à une déduction fiscale à hauteur
de 50 % du coût des travaux et qui
concerne actuellement des opérations qui
restituent en l'authenticité
architecturale d'une bâtisse visible
depuis la voie publique alors la
question que je souhaiterais vous poser
c'est de savoir si vous pensez qu'il
faudrait pouvoir étendre le champ
d'application de ce label par exemple
aux communes de plus de 20000 habitants
ou alors aux travaux qui sont faits à
l'intérieur et qui ne sont pas visibles
depuis l'extérieur oui monsieur
nous nous souten cette demande de la
Fondation du patrimoine qui est une
sorte de complément à l'action de l'État
qui
reçoit la possibilité de donner des
aides fiscales au nom de l'État pour un
certain nombre de de bâtiments on
considère que en effet il faudrait
étendre le ce privilège en quelque sorte
au travaux qui ne sont pas visibles de
au bâtiment qui ne sont pas visibles de
la vue de la rue ça c'est un premier
point et comme vous l'avez dit justement
à cause de ce débat que nous avons
maintenant on pense que ce serait
intéressant que les les travaux qui se
fait à l'intérieur et donc notamment
tout ce qui tourne autour de l'isolation
des combles ou des façades internes pour
être pris en compte donc ça je pense que
c'est une très bonne évolution donc nous
en tout cas ministère de la Culture on
est aux côtés de la Fondation du
Patrimoine pour porter cette proposition
qui permettrait de on va dire d'épargner
les façades extérieures en fait
oui et aussi peut-être de préserver les
décors intérieurs c'est à dire que s'il
y a une subvention de la formation du
patrimoine elle sera octroyée à des
isolations intérieures qui sont
respectueuses aussi des décors dans une
logique un peu proche de celle des PSMV
moi que je trouve assez assez
intéressantes patrimoine c'est pas
seulement le la façade le fameux
façadalisme c'est aussi le l'intérieur
donc
nous on y sera tout à fait tout à fait
favorable
très bien ce que quelqu'un souhaiterait
ajouter quelque chose oui oui
merci à vous monsieur la porte
juste un petit un petit complément
et puis réagir à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure sur
je pense qu'il faut il faut un petit peu
aussi tempérer quoi je dire oui il y a
le bâti avant 48 mais c'est vrai qu'on a
aussi un sacré boulot pour tout le reste
et que je pense pas que ce soit
l'hygiéniste je pense que c'est vraiment
un besoin je veux dire des gens qui
vivent avec des factures de chauffage
qui ne peuvent plus payer dans des
conditions qui sont très des complexes
il y a aussi une vraie question du coup
sanitaire et une urgence aussi en lien
avec effectivement le réchauffement
climatique et ça et l'action qu'on peut
mener donc effectivement faut voir tout
cet ensemble là et c'est justement du
coup la difficulté en tout cas
qu'on va arriver qu'on essaye de essaie
de résoudre pour s'adapter justement à
chaque à chaque spécificité et c'est
vrai qu'on voit bien en fait on a un
petit peu plutôt sur le bâti ancien une
nécessité un besoin d'agir avec du sur
mesure et qu'elle a on a plutôt quelque
chose qui est plutôt sur du
prêt-à-porter en fait et qui veut
s'adapter et donc c'est voilà comment
comment on arrive à trouver
mieux s'adapter sur sur le bâti sur le
bâti ancien moi j'avais plus une
question c'est c'est sûr ce qu'on
réfléchit aussi sur comment on peut agir
plus localement et avoir de spécificités
beaucoup plus locales et donc en
s'appuyant évidemment sur sur les
collectivités mais est parti mais du
coup
et puis Françoise Gatel également parce
que je sais qu'elle a intéressé aussi
par ça et c'est vrai qu'on a eu pas mal
et on a pas mal de plateformes de
rénovation de rénovation thermique qui
existe sur sur pas mal
d'intercommunalité
je pense qu'il faudrait plutôt les
développer qu'on en est à minima une par
intercommunalité avec justement
l'ingénierie de l'accompagnement qui
répond aussi à la question souvent de la
porte d'entrée en tout cas de la
visibilité et puis surtout d'avoir un
accompagnement humain quoi en tout cas
sur qu'est-ce que je dois faire
justement j'ai un bâtiment de ce type là
comment je dois je dois avancer et
l'avantage sur l'aspect sur l'aspect
local c'est qu'effectivement on va pas
agir de la même manière en Alsace que en
Isère ou ailleurs parce qu'il y a des
spécificités liées liées au bâti il y a
l'histoire etc et donc je trouvais que
cet intérêt là en tout cas d'avoir cette
réflexion et d'avoir une ingénierie
locale me paraissait important et
l'autre aspect aussi je suis allé il y a
pas longtemps dans une opération coeur
de cœur de ville là donc rénovation
centre-ville ancien et c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient pas un bâtiment un bâti
exceptionnel classique voilà de de
petites villes c'est vrai que quand on
regarde de près je crois qu'il y avait
20% des bêtes des logements qui étaient
préoccupés
souvent liés justement parce que ils
sont pas rénovés et que du coup personne
ne veut les habiter et le reste qui
devait être en passant thermique enfin
donc du coup considéré comme voilà et
donc sur lequel on sait qu'il va falloir
faire des travaux et c'est vrai que
quand on regarde de près on s'aperçoit
que ça va être compliqué enfin
l'isolation par l'extérieur pour le coup
là elle est quasi impossible avec les
rues etc donc en gros on peut agir
peut-être sur les menuiseries les
combles la ventilation de chauffage
voilà en tout cas avoir ces types de
réflexion là mais on voit qu'il va
falloir qu'on s'adapte et que peut-être
on n'aura pas des performances qui sont
exceptionnelles mais que peut-être il y
a une réflexion à avoir de de
travailler sur par quartier en fait et
c'est ça va dans le sens d'ailleurs de
ces opérations coeur de vie le cœur de
village etc pour se dire comment sur
l'ensemble d'un quartier on peut avoir
une intervention justement qui tienne
compte à la fois du patrimoine qui
améliore les les la fois l'aspect des
bâtiments le confort thermique
on a en ayant en allant vers le meilleur
mais on sait que voilà peut-être que sur
ces bâtiments là effectivement il faudra
des exonérations parce que sinon toute
façon on pourra pas les utiliser et donc
je me dis que ça si on réfléchit plutôt
à l'échelle à l'échelle locale ça peut
être des éléments intéressants mais
évidemment qui sort du cadre quoi et
donc à un moment donné accepter de
pouvoir sortir du cadre donc voilà du
coup c'était plus une réflexion mais
savoir si c'est quelque chose qui vous
trouviez
sur ce sujet là nous avons nous dans les
Hauts-de-France
signer une convention maisons paysanne
avec la région qui a qui a qui a mis en
place une dynamique depuis plusieurs
années pour que je sois pris en compte
le patrimoine sur les cinq départements
de la région patrimoine rural qu'il soit
habitable ou pas c'est à dire tout ce
qui fait en fait le sujet de notre
mobilisation maison paysanne l'outil de
travail c'est dépendance voilà tout ce
qui fait le cadre de vie rural mais
l'habitable aussi important de le dire
et ce sont des lignes budgétaires
importantes chaque année qui sont
attribués à des propriétés à privées ou
public pour les inciter à restaurer
comme on dit dans les règles de l'art
c'est à dire qu'il y a un accompagnement
ces maisons de paysanne donc qui
instruit les dossiers qui les fait
remonter éventuellement ou qui qui donne
son avis sur les devis le thème du devis
est fondamental parce que par le biais
du devis vous contactez l'entreprise
vous êtes en rapport avec l'entreprise
souvent c'est très difficile d'avoir
contact avec des entreprises et en fait
comme les les dossiers sont instruits
sur la base de fournitures de devis ça
nous permet d'avoir un dialogue avec les
entreprises de les contacter et
éventuellement de le faire évoluer sur
des programmes de travaux auxquels ils
n'ont pas pensé parce qu'ils n'ont pas
la culture éventuellement ou parce que
il y a pas eu ce dialogue par le maître
d'ouvrage qui n'y connaît rien il le dit
je connais rien donc voilà donc il y a
besoin d'un accompagnement et cet
accompagnement aujourd'hui est efficace
on constate que les gens sont preneurs
parce qu'ils ont quand même des
subventions des aides auxquelles
s'ajoutent le label de la Fondation du
Patrimoine et donc c'est vrai que la
Fondation du Patrimoine elle peut
effectivement avoir une action très
importante et là moi j'ai été 10 ans
délégué dans mon département et j'ai vu
l'efficacité
mais bon comme elle est surtout les
fronts la Fondation du Patrimoine un
moment donné l'argent faut le trouver et
les collectivités territoriales
aujourd'hui ont un rôle très important
ils ont compris la plupart que le
patrimoine c'était pas simplement une
nostalgie ou etc c'est on va dire de
l'activité économique dans le c'est de
l'attractivité c'est de l'insertion ce
sont des métiers qui méritent qu'on les
mette en valeur on en a pas beaucoup
parlé mais je rappelle que depuis 2006
ou maison paysanne avait travaillé pour
élaborer le référentiel du baccalauréat
restauration du bâti ancien qui existe
depuis 2006 il n'y a que 27
établissements
en France qui présente une terminale
seulement qui propose ce type de
baccalauréat c'est à dire 3% aujourd'hui
ce qui montre bien aussi le problème
franco-français vis-à-vis du travail
d'Emmanuel aujourd'hui les métiers du
bâtiment métier du BTP comme on les
appelle sont des métiers de relégation
pour la plupart des jeunes ils ont bien
compris que c'était pas quelque chose
qui était sexy séduisant etc on les a
mis là parce que on leur a fait
comprendre qu'ils étaient incapable de
faire autre chose il faut arrêter
d'avoir cette vision parce que nous les
métiers que nous mettons en avant dans
les savoir-faire les formations que nous
avons sont des métiers d'experts sont
des métiers où on retrouve le sens de
ces métiers éternels qui sont devenus
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui les métiers d'art
il y a un glissement dans le vocabulaire
aujourd'hui et et parallèlement à ce
glissement vers le haut les métiers
d'autrefois éternel sont devenus des
métiers d'art les métiers d'aujourd'hui
sont devenus les métiers de n'importe
quoi on le voit au niveau de la
sémantique ce sont des façades ce sont
des fenêtriers ce ne sont pas des
métiers il fallait trier c'est un poseur
de fenêtres il est pose souvent très mal
un façadier s'il fait du décor on est
dans l'obsolescence et derrière il y a
du PVC souvent
donc voilà on est vraiment dans le grand
n'importe quoi et je pense que beaucoup
de collectivités territoriales ont
compris l'intérêt de travailler dans ce
sens là on a des OPAH dans une
communauté de communes de
Picardie où je suis avec un volet
patrimoine il faut savoir que ça existe
aussi et c'est vrai que beaucoup d'élus
ne savent pas que quand on fait une
opération on peut inclure ce volet
patrimoine et là on va travailler sur
quelque chose qui va éduquer le regard
des des habitants de la population de la
du territoire qui ont été habitués à ce
qu'on comment dirais-je dévalorise la
culture qui était la leur en particulier
chez nous c'est beaucoup de culture de
bâti en terre et en bois et ça n'a pas
bonne presse ça n'a jamais eu bonne
presse on dit travail aujourd'hui c'est
en train de changer mais c'est considéré
comme un matériau de pauvres c'est un
matériau qui n'est pas solide etc donc
on a on a véritablement dans
l'imaginaire collectif et populaire tout
un travail à faire et je pense que
aujourd'hui l'opportunité que nous donne
c'est urgence dans laquelle nous sommes
peut-être une aubaine pour justement
créer des dynamiques vertueuses et
entraîner tout le monde vers quelque
chose qui soit on va dire dans le bien
commun et qui ne qui n'est pas d'effet
pervers négatif qu'on n'aurait pas prévu
parce que pour l'instant on est on est
là dedans pour l'instant on est
là-dedans donc voilà donc moi je pense
que les collectivités territoriales
c'est intéressant on a aussi des
conventions avec les cieux il faut en
parler ils sont présents sur tout le
territoire les cieux et ils font du
conseil journalier auprès des communes
mais aussi auprès des des des jeunes
scolaires etc donc tout ça ce sont des
synergies qui peuvent se mettre en place
sur les territoires et qui peuvent avoir
beaucoup d'effets sur justement la prise
de conscience que l'écologie sauver la
planète c'est l'affaire de tous voilà
comme ça je vois la chose et je pense
qu'on peut travailler dans ce sens là
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur est-ce que vous souhaitez
très bien oui oui juste un mot sur le
sur la question des collectivités c'est
une approche qui est intéressante parce
que
les collectivités vont en principe avoir
à coeur de protéger justement le
patrimoine qui est immédiatement sous
leur sous leur gamme on peut faire
beaucoup de choses avec un PLU et encore
mieux avec un site patrimonial
remarquable pour protéger finement
justement le patrimoine empêchait des
isolations par l'extérieur voir et ça
serait très important repérez très
finement il faudrait le faire
systématiquement les portes anciennes
les dernières portes anciennes qui
méritent d'être conservés les repérer et
les protéger par un PLU donc on peut
faire les choses probablement beaucoup
plus finement de près que que de loin en
fait j'avais préparé une question qui
allait tout à fait dans le sens de ce
que de ce que vous dites on évoquait
tout à l'heure on va dire les les
bâtiments le bâti qui est qui est
protégé d'une manière ou d'une autre
mais moi je suis très inquiète pour les
bâti qui n'est protégé absolument pas
protégé donc le bâti de nos petits
villages de nos hameaux etc et sur
lesquels pour l'instant tout est on peut
faire tout et n'importe quoi et je me
posais la question de savoir si
s'il ne faudrait pas rendre
l'identification de ce patrimoine
peut-être obligatoire d'une manière ou
d'une autre pour pouvoir
avoir un regard régulier sur lui et pour
éviter en fait qu'on se retrouve au
moment du de la signature du permis de
démolir sans pouvoir faire quelque chose
c'est tout à fait possible il faut juste
que les élus se saisissent des outils
qui existent parce que le PLU le permet
mais le PLU c'est ça qui est à peu
paradoxal rend obligatoire la protection
de l'environnement mais pas du
patrimoine mais si les élus sont
sensibilisés à la question ils peuvent
inclure dans leur plu une protection
particulière pour le patrimoine recenser
les les immeubles ou le ou les éléments
de second œuvre il y a énormément de
choses possibles simplement les élus se
saisissent pas de cette opportunité elle
est peut-être pas suffisamment connue
mais en tout cas c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui est une voix importante alors
après il peut y avoir une modification
de modification législative qui rend
obligatoire la prise en compte du
patrimoine mais alors là on est à un
autre niveau mais c'est une réflexion
qu'on a nous au ministère de la Culture
on pourrait peut-être imaginer une
démarche incitative de l'État le soir
pour accompagner les études qui
permettraient de faire cette
identification
sur cette question justement du repérage
du patrimoine qui est fondamental il y a
la question de l'inventaire des
richesses artistiques de la France
l'inventaire de Malraux qui est très
généralement alors là c'est un peu
triste parce que c'est l'une des
domaines patrimoniaux enfin quasiment le
seul qui a été décentralisé et on
s'aperçoit en fait que les régions
travaillent sur des problématiques assez
lunaires et à chaque fois que je
rencontre un responsable de l'inventaire
je lui dis mais est-ce que vous êtes en
train d'inventorier en ce moment les
portes anciennes les croisés anciennes
qui sont en train de disparaître avec
toutes les spécificités régionales et on
me dit non non on travaille sur le
l'architecture
influencée par l'Orient enfin sur des
choses qui sont très intéressantes sur
les œuvres des architectes femmes qui
sont des thèmes très tout à fait
intéressant mais sur lequel il y a pas
d'urgence en fait particulière j'ai
l'impression que l'État n'a
malheureusement pas les moyens
aujourd'hui d'orienter en fait la
politique de de l'inventaire et alors
petite anecdote dans le jeu notre prix
du second œuvre nous avons un membre
distingué qui s'appelle Arnaud Tiercelin
qui travaille dans une DRAC et qui prend
sur son ses week-ends
cette question ne serait-ce que pour
avoir des modèles pour plus tard quand
on enlèvera les blocs les blocs porte en
PVC et que quelqu'un qui veut refaire
une porte qui ressemble au modèle qui
était dans sa région encore faut-il
qu'on en ait un certain nombre de
relevés et la question des matériaux
tech aussi tous ces matériaux qu'on
enlève enfin ça va être dans le dans le
document qu'on va vous distribuer il
faudrait que les ABS puissent conserver
les exemplaires les plus intéressants
pour servir de de modèle et montrer aux
gens pourquoi c'est beau aussi il faut
juste rappeler quand même que vous
l'avez très bien dit mais en tirer les
conséquences la compétence a été
transférée aux régions donc l'état
l'État a un rôle de coordination mais
c'est la la responsabilité première ce
sont les régions et donc
aux élus il faudrait
qu'il faut s'adresser donc
chacune des régions donc c'est un faisan
quand on donne la parole aux
associations du patrimoine on est
tellement passionné alors
comment pour les élections
présidentielles nous avions préparé un
document commun qui s'appelle le
manifeste pour la protection du
patrimoine dans lequel effectivement
cette question que vous soulevez madame
le Président était voilà vous l'avez sur
l'inventaire de la même manière que on
considérait que pour mieux défendre le
patrimoine qui est un bien commun ça a
été dit il faudrait lui donner un
accroche un accrochage constitutionnel
si un jour l'occasion le fait se
présente
on a on on a besoin on en a besoin aussi
d'avoir un référé protection du
patrimoine pour éviter que du jour au
lendemain
une maison saine non protégée puisse
être liquidée sans qu'on est à peine le
temps de réagir donc les associations
réclament effectivement qu'il y ait une
meilleure protection juridique aussi du
patrimoine or ces dernières années on a
vu beaucoup de dispositions qui ne vont
pas dans dans ce sens donc il y aurait
besoin aussi de de rehausser tout cela
et la première des choses pour agir
c'est de connaître et donc il faut
connaître ce patrimoine qui fait c'est
pas seulement une côté de nostalgie vous
avez bien compris c'est aussi
l'attractivité de nos territoires ce
sont les logements de demain on a besoin
de logement dans les centres-villes et
là on est en train de d'avoir des
centres villes qui vont devenir bientôt
des musées si j'ose dire c'est-à-dire
mais des musées sans visiteurs si ça
continue donc on a besoin on a besoin
besoin de travailler sur tout ce
patrimoine ancien
non protégé 10 millions de logements
c'est tout même pas un pari et ce
patrimoine est un patrimoine durable
je viens du ministère des Finances à
l'origine à fort longtemps donc je sais
faire des calculs aussi économiques je
peux dire ce le patrimoine ancien et et
d'un patrimoine très rentable pour
l'environnement donc c'est le bon le bon
bilan le bon plan en matière
environnementale c'est le patrimoine sa
patrimoine durable il a franchi les
années des décennies des siècles et nous
on souhaite qu'on fasse cet
investissement ce bon choix j'allais
dire
pour le patrimoine oui monsieur
les documents d'urbanisme qui pourrait
être considérés comme des outils au
niveau des élus il faudrait plutôt que
de laisser à leur liberté le choix de
faire cette inventaire des bâtiments
remarquables patrimoniaux sur le
territoire quand le pays lui se fait
d'autant plus qu'il se fait aujourd'hui
à échelle intercommunale ce sont des
pays
il serait intéressant de rendre
obligatoire cet inventaire ce que dans
certains cas les élus sont pas motivés
ils sont pas ils ont un niveau de
culture qui leur permet peut-être pas
d'avoir cette priorité chacun bon a le
droit de penser comme il veut mais le
problème c'est que décisions qui sont
prises une fois qu'elles sont prises
dans le document s'il y a pas obligation
on peut rien faire et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné ça peut être un moyen si
c'est inventaire existe et si on a déjà
un certain nombre d'éléments qui sont
actés dans ce document qui lui aussi est
opposable de pouvoir on va dire
s'opposer à des destructions ou d'avoir
un œil sur
qui aura été inventorié et qui fera
l'objet on va dire de tous les soins à
partir de là il y a tout encore une fois
une synergie un accompagnement etc je
pense que là aussi c'est les politiques
qui peuvent faire évoluer cet outil et
le rendre beaucoup plus efficace qu'il
ne l'est et c'est vrai aussi pour
l'opérah tout à l'heure il faudrait
qu'il y ait dans toutes les OPA h n'ont
pas simplement installer des douches
chez les gens ou alors mettre des volets
roulants parce que souvent comme ça que
ça se fait on voit à fleurir des
fenêtres en PVC sur des territoires les
élus ça ne gêne pas du tout dans le
cahier des charges il y a rien qui dit
que c'est pas interdit il faudrait qu'il
y ait un volet patrimoine quelque part
surtout sur ces territoires ruraux ou
souvent ces OPH sont justifiés mais
souvent
se font sans cahier des charges
exigeants par rapport au patrimoine et
là encore c'est le politique qui peut
inclure cette obligation d'avoir le
volet
au bon endroit voilà voilà donc ça fait
presque trois heures en fait que nous
échangeons c'est des échanges vraiment
passionnants merci beaucoup je vous
remercie vraiment d'être venu et voilà
je vous propose de terminer cette
audition merci